hi everyone I am myang and welcome to
this amazing ethical hacking course by
simply learn but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these type of videos and
find them interesting subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so let's get started we will be briefing
you with the detail introduction to what
ethical hacking is after that types of
ethical hacking who is an ethical hacker
and what an ethical hacking career is
after that ethical hacking career moving
forward we will see ethical hacking
tools ethical hacking certifications YC
certification moving forward we will see
installing K Linux basic commands and
Linux for ethical hacking speaking of
interviews we have covered you along
with the most frequently Asked ethical
hacking interview questions to help you
correct the toughest interviews and so
on with with that mind if you want to
embark on a successful career as a cyber
security professional then our
postgraduate program in cyber security
this pgb program in cyber security is
designed to equip with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
you will get foundational to advance
skills through industry leading cyber
security certification courses in the
program first your career in the field
of cyber security with this
comprehensive curriculum covering
certification aligned courses the course
link is in the description box below
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Phillip
I'm 61 years old and last year I upskill
with simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the it sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples and was led by highly skilled
certified instru instructors I worked
with many companies before as a a
security analyst and architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with infosis as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
so let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information
a hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems now here there are
some key words that we need to
understand first and foremost exploit
when you're exploiting weaknesses
weaknesses are technically called
vulnerabilities which are basically
design flaws misconfiguration errors
usage of default usernames and passwords
which have not been modified so any
misconfiguration or anything that has
been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're are not allowed to do and when
you say a hacker is a person who tries
to hack it's basically a person with
malicious intent trying to gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it they find a
varability that is a weakness or a flaw
and then they misuse it to gain access
to that particular Network so here in
the diagram you can see that a sender on
the left hand side is trying to send
some data to the receiver on the right
hand side the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets within let's look at a business
case scenario into hacking now there is
an organization uh everybody's going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified uh by the hacker which
means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or get it's connected to
the organization demanding a ransom for
the data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lumpsum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and uh make these ransomware demands so
the company then uh wants to figure out
even if having a security system in
place how was the hacker able to hack
their systems thus one of the employees
comes up with a brilliant idea of
identifying viabilities in the network
uh to proactively search for any flaws
that have been left behind uh so that
they can plug those laws and nobody can
misuse them thus they figure out that
they want to hire a ethical hacker who
would help them identify the security
posture of the organization identify the
weaknesses vulnerabilities and flaws and
help them remedy those flaws so that in
future scenarios these scenarios will
not happen so before we go into an
ethical hacker let's understand what are
the types of hackers so what are the
types of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person uh who is very Adept with
Compu computers they have good
programming skills they understand how
operating system works they understand
how networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and V abilities within
all of these aspects and then they
understand and know how to misuse these
flaws to get a outcome which would be
detrimental to the health of the
organization so there are six type of
hackers that have been identified black
hat hackers white hat hackers gray hat
script kitties nation sponsored hackers
and activists so black hat hackers are B
basically uh the malicious hackers who
have malicious intent and have
criminalistic Tendencies they want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that uh they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective uh these guys are
also known as crackers the main aspect
of these uh people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a blackhe hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a whitee hacker on the other
hand is also an ethical hacker or a
security analyst who's an individual who
will do exactly the same thing that a
blackhead hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gray hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kites are people uh who are technically
not much aware about what hacking is uh
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers they have
no technical knowledge of what they're
doing it's just a hit or miss for them
so they just get their hands on a tool
they try to execute those tools uh if
the hack works it works otherwise
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with Mal's intent who just want to
have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state sponsored hackers as the name
suggest these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their p on um on their organizations to
spy on their enemies to spy on various
countries and try to figure out uh the
aspirations of those countries so this
is basically a spying activity where you
are technically trying to get access to
other Count's resources and then try to
spy on them to figure out what their
activities have been or what their
future plans have been and then we have
the activists who is an individual who
has a political agenda to promote and
they promote it by doing hacking so uh
these guys what is the difference
between a blackhe hat hacker and a
activist the blackhe Hat hacker may try
to hide their identity a activist will
claim responsibility of what they have
done so for them it's a political agenda
political cause and they will try to
hack various organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website and posting the
messages that they want to promote on
these websites so what exactly is
ethical hacking then we have discussed
the types of hackers we have identified
a malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent uh of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have disc disc what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what
they're allowed to do and what they are
not allowed to do and the ethical
hackers would function within those
Scopes would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again ethical hacker is a
highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can trouble
shoot they're technically very Adept at
Computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can basically be uh very good
with programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want ethical hacker
to be a good developer of applications
we want them to understand programming
in such a way that they can create
scripts they can write their own short
programs like viruses worms Trojans or
exploits which would help them achieve
the objective that they have set out for
so uh here you can see the ethical
hacker they individuals who perform a
security assessment of their companies
with the permission of cons concerned
authorities so what is a security
assessment a security assessment is
finding out the exact security posture
of the organization by identifying what
security controls are in place how
they've been configured and if there are
any gaps in the configurations
themselves so an organization will hire
a ethical hacker they they would give
the ethical hacker the information about
what information is or what security
controls what firewalls what idss ipss
inen detection or inen prevention
systems antiviruses are already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization next shti
will guide you through the career of an
ethical hacker with the increase in the
number of cyber crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list hi guys
this is shuti from Simply learn and
today I will run you through this video
on ethical hacking career so let's get
started and explore the world of ethical
hacking let's begin with a few facts did
you know that by the year 2021 there
will be 3.5 million cyber security job
openings that is a huge number isn't it
and also according to the US Bureau of
Labor Statistics there will be 28%
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes e ethical
hackers this proves that there is a
great demand for ethical hackers at the
moment as I mentioned earlier the number
of cyber crimes across the world will
increase as the digital era will only
continue to grow organizations will be
on the lookout to hire professionals who
can fight these cyber crimes and protect
the company's data and to fight these
cyber crimes we will require individuals
who can think like a hacker and who is
that well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is stained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an an ethical
hacker you might wonder how to start
your ethical hacking career right well I
will take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of 2 years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move onto the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the CCNA and coma
Security Plus certifications finally the
last step to become an ethical hacker is
to clear the certified ethical hacker
examination CH certification is provided
by the EC Council it trains the
candidate to protect a company's Network
by using the same tools and methods that
a hacker would use the CH exam will have
a duration of 4 hours with 125 number of
questions questions if the candidate
clears this exam then he or she will
become a certified ethical hacker now
that you know the steps to become an
ethical hacker let's look into the skill
sets which are required to help you
achieve these steps first and foremost
an ethical hacker needs to have an
in-depth knowledge of the working of the
operating systems knowledge of Windows
Linux and Macintosh operating systems is
required for penetration testing
creating exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as C C++ HTML Python and PHP will be
very helpful basic knowledge of
networking tcpip protocols and OSI model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases knowledge of SQL
nosql post gr SQL is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-re able format and vice versa
Crypt analysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
Crypt analysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
crypt analysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessis
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the Deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining IDs
IPS and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into by an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will per perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using using different hacking tools
and techniques an ethical hacker can
also apply for the role of an
information security analyst there is a
difference between the job rules of a
penetration tester and that of an
information security analyst here the
candidate will be required to primarily
design and protect the organization's
network from various cyber attacks
finally the candidate is also required
to document the identified security
breaches so that it can be omitted the
next time the responsibilities of a
security consult consultant is more or
less similar to that of an information
security analyst that we saw previously
as a security consultant you will be
responsible to design Implement and
maintain various Security architectures
in addition to this you're also required
to upgrade the security systems as and
when required finally an ethical hacker
can also apply to the role of an
information security manager as the name
suggests this role will require the
candidate to possess managerial skills
as an information security manager is
responsible to head the it and the
information security team now that we
have seen the responsibilities the
skills and the steps to become an
ethical hacker let's have a look at the
different companies hiring ethical
hackers to name a few we have Bank of
America Ernest and Young KPMG Urban Pro
and IBM let's now look into the salary
structure of an ethical hacker well in
India the average annual salary of a
certified ethical hacker is nearly 4
476,000 rupees and in the US the average
annual salary of a certified ethical
hacker is
$91,000 now I will guide you through a
sample resume of a penetration tester as
you can see on your screens this is a
sample resume of a penetration tester we
will look into this resume closely and
understand how your resume should look
like if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name and your email
ID
and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of your current job
profile it is preferred to add your
LinkedIn profile link here and also your
GitHub profile link if you have one as I
mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration test term and
hence we have to have more than 2 years
of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is is that of a software
tester and second is that of a
penetration tester you would have to
mention your latest or current
experience at the beginning you can
mention your job role and the company
and the duration under which you can
list out the various responsibilities
that you are looking into currently if
you are a penetration tester you can
mention responsibilities such as
security monitoring blackbox testing
documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a CCNA certific ification will be
preferred followed by a certified
ethical hacker certification which is a
must if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester in addition to it
the certified expert penetration tester
certification will also hold a great
Advantage after mentioning the
certifications you can go ahead and
mention your skill sets here we have the
technical skills and non-technical
skills under technical skills you can
mention the programming languages that
you know here we have C C++ Java Pearl
you can also mention the operating
systems that you have worked on for
example Windows Linux Unix and in
addition to the programming languages
and the OS you can also mention the
tools that you know such as nmap
Metasploit tools which will be helpful
if you are applying for the role of a
penetration tester then you can also
mention encryption Technologies
knowledge of SQL and Bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in
eatons you can mention that here as well
under the non-technical skills you can
mention various competitions that you
have taken part in and the games that
you like and other extra curricular
activities finally you can also mention
the projects undertaken under the
projects undertaken you can talk about
the various projects that you have
performed in your company or outside the
company here we have two projects one as
a software test engineer and second one
as a penetration tester so this is how a
resume of a penetration tester will look
like so let's look talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize uh in their testing scenarios to
be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them uh nessus is
a vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within uh
operating systems within networks so
they come with their readymade databases
of all the vulnerabilities that have
already been identified and the scan the
network against that database to find
out any possible flaws or any possible
vulnerabilities that currently exist on
the host or the operating system or on
the network similarly there would be
application scanners like uh actic or
Arachne that would help you scan
applications and identify flaws within
those applications as well now all of
these are automated tools the essense of
ethical hacker is when these tools churn
out the reports the ethical ha hacker
can understand these reports analyze
them identify the flaws and then craft
their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access security controls mechanisms
that are already in place how can they
do that with the tool called Metasploit
you see that Big M there on the right
hand side that M logo is for a tool
called Metasploit which is a penetration
testing tool what is a penetration
testing tool it is that tool that will
allow a ethical hacker to craft their
exploits or choose their exploits for
the vulnerabilities that have been
identif ified by nessus since we are
interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas flit helps us do that wire
Shar would be used in the background
while we doing both the activities using
nessus or Metasploit to keep a track of
what packets are being sent and by
received on the network which will help
us analyze those packets so whenever I
run an SS scanner I would run a Yar in
the background it will capture the data
packets and I can go through those data
packets and analyze that data packets to
identify what nesses is actually trying
to do similarly when I try to attack a
machine using exploit on metas exploit I
will keep on wire shockk running in the
background to capture the data package
that have been sent and the responses
that I've received from the victim so
that I can also go through through those
packets and analyze the responses and
analyze the attack whether it was
successful to what extent was it
successful and basically will also give
me a validation a proof of the activity
that has happened nmap is another
automated tool that allows me to scan
for open ports and protocols so why
would I use nmap because Pro ports and
protocols become an entry point for a
hacker to gain access to devices for
example when we connect to a web server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https so if I'm
connecting to a web server using https
it is safe to assume that Port 443 on
the web server is open to accept those
connections similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand
understand what services are being
offered on that server so then I can
start analyzing that server identify
those flaws within those services and
then try to attack them if the
application that I'm analyzing is
connected to a database and I want to do
a SQL injection attack or if I if necess
tells me that there's a SQL injection
attack that may be possible on that
particular application I can use an
automated tool called SQL map or SQL map
that would allow me to automatically
craft all the queries that are required
for a SQL injection attack and help me
do that attack at the same time so here
I do not have to manually create my own
queries uh the SQL map tool would
automatically create them for me what I
would do is I would use nessus to
identify that particular flaw if nessus
reports that flaw I would then go use
the tool SQL map configure it to attack
that particular web server and when I
fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that that we would follow so there are
six steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
recognizance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical Hacker's
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a
windows-based server and I use a
particular tool to attack it but it
actually turns out to be a Linux based
server my attacks are going to be
unsuccessful so I need to focus my
attack based on what is there at the
other end so in my information gathering
phase I want to identify all of that
information once I have that information
done I'm going to scan those servers
using tools like nmap that we just
talked about and we're going to try to
see the open ports open services and
protocols that are running on that
server that can give me possible entry
points within the network or within the
device or within the operating system at
the same time along with the scanning
with nmap I would run a vulnerability
scanner the nessus vulnerability scanner
we talked about or actic for
applications and then I will try to
identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access uh by either tracking passwords
or escalating privileges or exploiting
availability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist existing or
somebody changed the password that may I
may have cracked does I no longer have
access so what do I do to maintain my
access I install Trojans or backd door
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where I maintain my access I have hacked
them now I want to maintain my access so
I install a software which would give me
a backd door entry to that device no
matter what once I've done this I want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that I've been doing for example
installing a Trojan a Trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victim's machine so I want to hide
that if I have access data stores if I
have modified data I want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline does my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where I will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hiking tools like nmap HP to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again n map next p these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metas sploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use metas at the same time
uh you can craft your own scripts to
create a Trojan and install it on the
victim's machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you done
all of this we are going to create
reports that are going to be submitted
to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give about let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollar through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go
onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your priz
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gully bleating
most of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavish Ever After but sadly in the real
world that's not that doesn't happen
that often and if you're receiving those
mails it is very important that you
first research the validity of those
those Communications before you even
want to act upon them so why are humans
susceptible to social engineering
because humans have emotion machines do
not try pleading with a machine to give
you access to a account that you have
forgotten a password to the machine
wouldn't even know what you're doing try
pleading with a human sympathy or
empathy where you could try to create a
social injuring attack where you can
plead with them saying if I do not get
access to this account immediately I
might lose my job and then that would
put my family into problems somebody
would feel empathy or sympathy towards
you and help you reset that password and
give you access to that account it's how
good the attack is and how convincing
you are for the success of this attack
to happen so what is a familiarity
exploit attackers interact with victims
to gain information which will benefit
the attackers to crack credentials as
passwords if we want to reset our
passwords what do we we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
schol that you attended you probably
have that listed on your LinkedIn
profile where person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you were in right similarly it
might also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh I mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they're
trying to take a survey and the approach
you for a feedback on a particular
product that you have been utilizing and
they ask you these questions you
wouldn't think twice before giving those
answers as long as the request sounds
legitimate to us we are able to justify
that request we do answer those queries
so it's upon us to verify the
authenticity of the request coming in
before we answer it fishing as discussed
would be fraud emails which appear to be
coming from a trusted source so email
spoofing comes into mind uh fake
websites and so on so forth exploiting
human curiosity curiosity killed the cat
right so there was there's so many
physical attacks where hackers just keep
pen drives lying around in a parking lot
now this is open a generic attack
whoever Falls victim will fall victim so
if I just throw around a few USBS in the
parking lot obviously with Trojans
implemented on them some people who are
curious or who are looking for a couple
of freebies might take up those pen
drives plug them in their computers to
see what data is on the pen drives at
the same time once they plug in their
those pen drives on their computers the
virus or the Trojan would get infected
and cause harm to their machine then
exploiting human greed uh we just talked
about the Nigerian frauds and the
lotteries those kind of attacks the fake
money-making gimmicks now basically this
is where you pray upon the persons greed
kicking in and they clicking on those
links in order to uh get that money that
has been promised to them in that email
so one of the safest mechanism to keep
data private and to keep yourself secure
is using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the end user using the uh same key would
then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would look like EQ o r
XV GT for a end user wouldn't make any
sense but the person who has a key to
unscramble that would be able to convert
it back to computer and then understand
the meaning of that word so this is just
a substitution Cipher that is being
shown on the screen so what is the
alphabet the key is alphabet plus 3 so
C+ 3 alphabets that becomes e o becomes
q m becomes o so the key that is
utilized to scramble the data is the
character that you are at the third
character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e correspondent
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as a
ethical hacker you wouldn't be for
paying a ransom uh to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a crypt analysis Crypt analysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so Crypt analysis
can be done using various formats the
first one is a Brute Force attack second
is a dictionary attack attack third one
is a rainbow table attack a Brute Force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is
100% successful but may take a lot of
time a dictionary attack is where you
have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the cipher
text is compared with another Cipher
text you find out similarities and then
you try to work a reverse engineer your
way accordingly so let's have a quick
demo on cryptography before we be end
this session so to begin with the demo
of cryptography we are on a website
called spam mic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message turn a
short message into spam so what this
does is want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so whoever
is reading that spam mail would never
get an idea of the embedded message
within it so if I want to type in a
message here hi this is a secret message
the password is ASD at1 1234 and I want
to send this out to people or to one of
my colleagues but I want to send it out
in a secret manner so that others are
not aware of this so when I press on
encode what the algorithm would do is it
will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this is a secret
message the password is atate 1 234 or
ASD at1 234 gets converted into this now
if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
I've already said so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm REM remain needs to remain the
same so once they know that it is Spam
mimic what they can do is now in this
instance what I'm going to do is I'm
going to open up a new browser and I'm
going to go to the same website and at
this point in time I'm going to click on
decode when I click on decode I'm going
to paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.me Mage this is a secret message
the password is ASD at 1 234 and then I
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
I use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say AES which is the
strongest Cipher right now and I say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically uh if I
don't have the password over here if I
decrypt it you would see that the error
has occurred now if I type in the
password over here and then decrypt it
it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at the rate 1 2 3 4 so if I want to
keep my data secure from hackers I want
to scramble it in such a way that they
would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker to keep the data
secure so let's start looking at the
certifications so to be an ethical
hacker you must hold a certification
which specializes in ethical hacking or
in cyber security companies look for
candidates who are globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a certificate that has been
given by an organization that is
recognized globally and is well accepted
in the industry so these are the top
five certifications a candidate can
obtain the first one become a certified
ethical hacker then there is global
information assurance certification
penetration tester then offensive
security CER certified Professional
comia pentest Plus and finally the
license penetration tester now these
certifications are offered by different
organizations all of these organizations
are recognized globally and their
certifications are well accepted uh in
the technical space so let's start off
with the certified ethical hacker and
we'll look at uh the organizations that
provide these certifications and how we
can attain them so C or certified
ethical hacker in its current form is in
its version 10 that's been revised and
updated over a period of time EC council
is the certifying Authority for C they
have their own authorized training
centers through which you can attend
trainings give those exams get yourself
certified and thus become globally
certified and uh can be eligible to
apply for security related jobs it is a
very well-known certification and is
widely accepted at the same time it
would test the candidates knowledge of
security threats and preventive measures
now there are two types of exams that
you can give with ch one is a multiple
choice question exam which is
theoretical in nature they ask you
questions and you answer the correct one
you select the correct answers if you're
clear you get certified the second
certification nowadays is where there's
a practical exam associated with it
that's a uh you'll have to purchase the
voucher for that exam and give that exam
the Practical exam is held in a Virtual
Lab where they you're given scenarios
and based on those scenarios you have to
resolve the questions given to you and
give proof of the resolution which would
then uh get you certified as an ethical
hacker the theoretical exam in this
scenario is the fees is around $500 this
is for the multiple choice question exam
uh where you can pay the fees and you
can uh attend through a uh online portal
and you can give the exam directly the
exam is 4 hours long in which you have
to answer 125 questions now 4 hours for
125 questions seems a long time but it
isn't it's a very technical exam there
are scenario based questions and it
would take some time for you to analyze
and understand the question and then
identify the equivalent correct answer
so it's a very competitive exam and
you'll have to study really hard to
clear this exam as well the cut off for
passing varies from 60 to 85% so there
is no exact grade and all the questions
have different weightages so depending
on the questions that have been given
you and the way that you have answered
them you would pass at either 60% or you
would pass when you have scored 85% once
you are C certified which is a very
technical certification you will be
qualified to apply for job roles as a
penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications uh servers
switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
adapt in most most of these tools that
are required there are a lot of
practicals in this uh trainings and uh
if uh you successfully completed those
practicals clearing the exam is a easy
task with the practicals comes your
knowledge and would help you understand
how you would be performing penetration
tests in the real world an average
annual salary in the USA for a c
certified person is around
$91,000 and in India is around 476,000
odd rupees the salaries would vary as
far as organizations are concerned uh
more established organizations can
afford to pay a little bit more but
these are average R salaries that we
have seen across the market the next
certification is the gpen also known as
the global information assurance
certification penetration tester this
certification looks into the different
pen testing practices and methods also
focuses on the various problems and Pen
testing so again this is where you
getting certified as a penetration
tester so it's again a technical
certification where you're not knowledge
on networking applications and security
of which will be tested uh you will be
trained on this of course so the
training will include all these areas
where you need to focus identify those
problems and thus be ready for the real
world scenarios the candidate will have
to understand networking Concepts and
operating systems such as Linux and
windows and you should be very well
aware of the tcpip protocols this is
true for any of the technical
certifications for ethical hacking G is
the certific ation provider it's again a
very well-renowned and well accepted
certification Authority across the globe
the exam fees are
$1,899 $82 to15 questions to be answered
in 3 hours now why 82 to5 it depends on
the test that has been Associated and
depending on how you're answering those
questions uh you would be given those
many number of questions to begin with
but all of these need to be answered in
3 hours 74 % is the past percentage that
is required to clear this exam the
average annual salary in the USA is
around
$96,000 while in India it is around
similar to certified ethical hacking
then looking at the next certification
from offensive security called the OSP
uh offensive security certified
professional this is another penetration
testing certification highly technical
in nature and it is an entirely Hands-On
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about CH where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the Practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual Network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
Authority in this case offensive
security uh if you match their criterias
of whatever you have identified in those
reports you get certified here the
requirements of good understanding of
networking protocols how systems
function how K Linux operating system
functions and the candidate must
complete offensive Securities
penetration testing with the Ki Linux
course and pass the Hands-On exam so
this focuses purely on Ki Linux Ki Linux
is an operating system that is freely
distributed over the internet and comes
structured with around 300 plus tool
used for ethical hacking so this course
totally relies on KH Linux for you to
use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider as
stated is offensive security the name of
the course is ocp offensive security
certified professional exam is around
$800 to
$1,550 Now understand that this exam is
Technical and is Hands-On so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual Labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which You' have purchased the access to
that particular Labs the amount will
vary from $800 which would be the
minimum access days available to
$1,550 where the maximum number of days
would be given to you for practicing
once you're ready even during the time
time span of where you have that access
once you're ready for the exam you can
you can attempt the exam and clear the
average annual salary is similar around
$91,000 for the US market and 95,000
rupees in the Indian market then looking
at the comia pentest plus comia is
another certification Authority or a
certification provider a training
provider that that will help you get
yourself certified in the ethical
hacking space so they have certification
called pentest plus which is focused
towards penetration testing so it is an
intermediate level certification it
assesses the vulnerability assessment
and the penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of 3 to four years of hands-on
experience in the information security
field also a coma Security Plus or a
network Plus or equivalent knowledge is
required so in the network plus uh they
talk about securing networks and uh they
help you understand the OSI layers the
tcpip layers and help you understand the
protocols and all of those things so
having that knowledge is an added
Advantage the certificate provider is
comia and the cost of the exam is around
$349 maximum number of questions is
$85 and I think it's a 3our exam the
passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible 900 so the scale
is the minimum you can ever score is 100
if you're completely unprepared the
maximum you can score is 900 uh you get
a leeway of 150 marks for your uh
certifications so you have to score a
minimum of 750 to clear the exam average
annual salary for a Kamia certified
penetration test plus professional is
$97,000 in the US market and in the
Indian market it would be around 5 lakh
rupees then comes the license
penetration tester now this is an
advanced certificate again from EC
Council this is where AC Council gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the C
certification it is the Ultimus test
which tests the candidates penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
EC Council certified security analyst
once you clear that you you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are Hands-On
certifications so you will be given a
Virtual Lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports submit it to
the EC Council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criterias that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
Tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every 3 years so the validity
is 3 years after 3 years you will have
to be recertified or there is a
continuing Point education system over
there where you can score points by
publishing articles by attending
trainings or giving out trainings and
you can get yourself re certified it is
preferred that the candidate has CH and
the ecsa certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa EC
Council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration Tester the certificate
provider again is EC Council the license
penetration tester exam has a different
process the candidate must purchase an
exam dashboard for
$899 which is valid for a year so once
you purchase the voucher the validity is
one year uh you can prepare within that
one year and then give the exam and
attain the certification only once
you're ready the exam can be uh
scheduled and you can give that exam the
exam consists of three different levels
each level has three different
challenges the candidate must pass at
least one challenge in order to qualify
for the next level and for each level
the exam is 6 hours so this is a
grelling exam this is Hands-On they're
giving you challenges and they are going
to test you on your skills as a
penetration tester so be ready to be
very Hands-On for this kind of a
certification average annual salary in
the US is around $100,000 and above and
in India $825,000 and above so why do we
want to get the certification and what
would it mean by being a c certified uh
uh individual take this into
consideration you are applying for jobs
and uh you have been applying for cyber
security related jobs of course and you
go in for an interview in the interview
you asked quite a few questions and they
will be testing you on cyber security
Concepts so they will be asking you a
lot of technical questions about cyber
security about information security and
any other related topic so let's say in
a few minutes into the interview there
are some Concepts that you have not
brushed your skills upon and they ask
you about certifications and one of the
main certifications that is sought after
is the C certification and if you're not
certified that's where things can become
a little bit problematic where
organizations today very proactively
start looking for people or candidates
who are already certified rather than
take them on board and get them
certified so in this scenarios uh having
a certification would obviously help not
only to be
uh shortlisted for the job but the
certification involves a lot of training
which would help you understand the
concepts and prepare you for the
interview a lot better as well right so
getting yourself certified is quite
necessary in today's world let's look at
what the certification is all about the
certification involves a very Hands-On
training that trains an individual into
thinking about cyber security from a
hacker perspective and developing this
mindset is very important because To
Catch a Thief you have to think like a
thief teaches the candidate to spot
vulnerabilities in a system so it trains
you on how to identify flaws how to
verify that they exist and then how to
treat them as well like I said this is a
very sought after certification and
companies look for people who are
already certified as C or a certified
ethical hacker so what is this
certification all about uh this is a
globally accepted certification and it
tests the knowledge that a candidate
will have about threats and the
prevented preventive mechanisms so the
certification the exam itself will test
you on the parameters the training would
provide you with all the information
that you require to clear the exam and
to gain knowledge from a real world
perspective so will train a candidate to
think like a hacker it will train the
candidate to use the tools to identify
those flaws uh to spot those uh flaws in
the first place and it will give an
understanding to the candidate where to
look for those flaws in the first place
so essentially when you get certified as
a certified ethical hacker you become a
white hat hacker or a ethical hacker
which means that you will be looking at
flaws ethically and Reporting them to
those organizations the certifying
authorities the EC Council it is a very
wellknown and a widely accepted
certification Authority across the globe
it is based out of the United States but
the certification is valid across the
globe so what does it take to take the
exam and who can take the exam in the
first place now the basic criteria is
that a candidate should be 18 years and
above so any person who has completed an
official EC Council training is eligible
to attempt the exam without going
through an application process so there
are two ways you can actually attempt
the exam you either have work experience
that means you're already in the cyber
security space you already have some uh
you already have some handson knowledge
and you want to give the exam in that
scenario you just have to prove that you
have got two years of experience expence
with network or information security and
then you can apply to EC Council to
directly appear for the exam without
attending the training else you can then
approach EC counil and register yourself
for a training course after which you
can give the exam so there are two ways
that you can deal with it what are the
fees for these exam now the fee itself
is $500 for the exam candidates should
take the second route where they prove
that they have experience and they
directly want to appear for the exam
there is another additional 100 $1 of
application fee that they have to pay to
EC counsil for them to verify that you
actually have that experience and then
allow you to appear for the exam so what
are the exam questions like what what is
the exam all about the exam code is
312-50 and there are 125 questions that
need to be answered in 4 hours now that
sounds like a lot of time but trust me
it isn't the questions are descriptive
in nature they give you a scenario you
have to identify those keywords based on
the knowledge and the understanding that
you have and then gauge the correct
answer for that particular scenario and
the scenarios could be a little bit
complex could be a little bit confusing
the exam will be a multiple choice
question exam so one questions with four
answers if any question has multiple
answers they will mention it in the
question itself the pass percentage cuts
off at around 60 to 85% so there is no
fixed percentile every question has a
different grade every question has a
different value and and based on the
questions that you have been asked and
the correctness of the answers you would
either pass somewhere between 60 to 85%
the results are immediate so once you
complete the exam and you submit it it
will uh let you know that itself whether
you have cleared or not so what are the
skills that you require for this exam
you must have very good networking
skills and when we say networking skills
you should know your protocols you
should know how computers communicate
with each other uh the protocols like
https s FTP SMTP and anything about the
OSI layer you should be good with your
operating systems the candidate should
also have a very good knowledge about
operating systems and when we say
operating systems we want the candidate
to know about troubleshooting methods
and how the operating system work in the
first manner so you should have some
basic skills about operating systems and
the configuration of these operating
systems uh you should also know the
different types of cyber attacks such as
social engineering fishing and how to
prevent these attacks so this is the
exam skills the training prepares you
with all these skills the candidate must
be able to hack into an organization
system with permission and erase all
digital evidences so uh the training
itself will get you accustomed uh with
all the hacking phases how a hack is
constructed how a hack is made more
effective and how the hack evolves and
later on how you can delete all the
evidences of the hack that has happened
so for the exam you should have or you
should be very good with your networking
skills understanding protocols and how
they work configuring operating systems
and troubleshooting them you should be
able to classify different cyber attacks
and know how to launch them as well and
you should be able to hack into devices
and erase all digital evidences that may
have happened password cracking and
cryptography is also a very much
required skill to clear the exam there
must be a few rules followed and there
is a Code of Ethics from EC Council so
they essentially give you a
non-disclosure agreement ment before you
start the training which you have to go
through and you have to sign it submit
it to EC Council only then are you
allowed to go forward with the exam so
what are the exam all about what are the
topics within that exam and what kind of
questions would you get so there are
seven domains in this training based on
which they will ask you questions when
you say background uh background is
nothing but your knowledge on networking
skills U your knowledge on a little bit
of operating systems how Communications
happen how protols work and so on so
forth analysis would be where you
analyze certain attacks and you're able
to uh analyze let's say packets and base
on those packets you can identify
whether uh it's a legitimate packet or
is it a malicious packet with any
malicious data within it then with
security tools you are able to talk
about security as in the concepts of
security like confidentiality integrity
and availability Triad the IAA
identification authentication
authorization and accountability Tri
aspects uh and various other Concepts
that are there in security so you'll be
questioned on those topics as well tools
and programs ethical hacking carries a
lot of tools and you should be
conversent with those tools uh in the
during the training there will be
hundreds of tools that uh you would be
going through and you would be facing
questions on these tools so there would
be some basic questions like commands
that would be given to you to identify
what that command would execute or there
would be a specific scenario given to
you and then they would ask you which is
the most uh suitable tool that you would
utilize to crack that particular
scenario and then there's the
methodology of course of how or which
steps would you take in this particular
attack to be successful then we talk
about policies and the ethics so as you
can see all of these domains have
different weightage in the exam 21.79%
for your background so you can see the
background information is very much
important operating systems networking a
little bit of applic ations a little bit
of architecture of how things are
deployed now CH is normally an advanced
certification right so there are a few
presumptions that you already know a
little bit about uh active directory how
operating systems work uh how identity
management works so there's a little bit
of presumption that you have these
background knowledge but in the training
you can be prepped up for that knowledge
as well so it does contain a little bit
of insights about how these things work
analysis is where you're looking at some
scenarios and based on the evidences
given to you you can analyze what's
going on so that's at 20.73%
security which is the main topic is at 2
3.73% tools and programs related to
security would be at
28.9% the methodologies would carry a
weightage of
8.77 policies 1.90 and ethics
2.17% so you have 125 questions you can
figure out uh percentile wise how many
questions you would get on each of these
domains so let's have a look at these
domains a little bit more more the
background is about Network and
communication Technologies again like I
said protocols procedures Services how
computers work so ports on a computer
how uh how ports are utilized by
services and how Communications happen
over these services and these ports how
we can scan these ports to identify
what's going on and then try to find out
vulnerabilities within them then we have
got information security Technologies
and the information security threats as
well so when I want to launch an attack
on a device where would I find
vulnerabilities is it just on the
network uh do I look at the operating
system do I look at different
applications that are there on the
operating system and so on so forth so
where are the threats that's something
that we need to identify and that's what
this domain deals with so uh 27
questions from this domain then analysis
and assessment information security
assessment and Analysis and the security
assessment process so uh let's say
you're in a penetration test and you
want to to launch an attack what is the
assessment that you want to do before
you launch that attack what is the
process you want to conduct and how you
going to analyze the vulnerability in
the first place to identify which
penetration test or which attack you
should uh do at that particular point in
time then security would talk about
information security controls controls
would be all the uh security elements
that you can Implement to prevent uh
hacking so firewalls IDs IPS antiviruses
or endpoints all of these would be
included in this domain information
security attack detection so it's not
only about how you can attack you also
want to know if you're being attacked in
the first place so analysis would
basically identify how you're being
attacked and the detection is where
where you first detect that something is
wrong after which you can analyze it
right and how you can prevent uh
security attacks happening at your
organization as well so which firewall
would fit at what OSI layer what uh in
the architectural aspect where do you
want to place a ID IDs or an IPS where
would you want to place a firewall where
would you want to place a UTM to have a
layered approach a structur structured
approach towards security where a hacker
would have to peel off layers of
security to reach the data that they
wanted to get access to in the first
place so there will be 30 questions from
the security domain 16 questions on the
analysis and assessment domain the
fourth domain is the tools systems and
programs so this is where all the tools
that you would have
utilized presume so this is where all
the tools that you have utilized in the
ethical hacking scenario and there will
be questions asked about those tools so
in the training there are some tools
that are prescribed in the course where
you'll have to concentrate on those
tools you'll have to get your hands on
on those tools to understand how those
tools work and then give appropriate
answers in this domain so there would be
36 questions for tools systems and
programs then the fifth domain is
procedures and methodology information
security procedures and assessment
methodologies would be asked over here
so how would you uh conduct a test how
would you conduct a vulnerability
assessment what is the method and the
procedures that you would follow in
conducting these tests so there would be
around 11 questions for this domain the
sixth one is regulations and policies so
this is all about uh some Basics that
you need to be aware about uh for
information security policies and
Frameworks uh like ISO 2701 pcss and the
these uh regulations that are available
in the real world that you can that can
help you or guide you to place a
security architecture on your
organization these questions are not
going to be in depth about any of the
laws or policies it's just checking your
awareness whether you are aware of these
laws or policies and where they can be
implemented so we can see that only a
couple of questions that would come in
regulations and policies and then ethics
ethics is the code of conduct cond of
how you are expected to behave as a
ethical hacker what is expected out of
your job rule what you should be doing
and what you shouldn't be doing so there
would be around three questions of
Ethics in the exam now let's look at a
few sample questions from the exam as
well so this will help you get an idea
what the exam questions would be so
consider the attack scenario given below
there are five steps listed step one
starts with user browses a web page the
second step is where user uh web server
replies with the requested page and sets
a cookie on the user's browser in the
third step attacker steals the Cookie by
either creating an attack of on the
network for sniffing or at the
application with cross site scripting or
sending a fake mail or uh hosting a fake
website by a social engineering attack
which is a fishing attack in the fourth
step attacker gets access using whatever
they have done and orders a product
using modified cookies and in the fifth
step the product is actually delivered
to the attacker's address whereas the
bill is footed by by the victim so what
is the attack that is happening here
identify the web application attack is
it a session fixation attack is it a
unvalidated redirect attack is it a
cookie poisoning attack or is it a
denial of service attack so again going
through these steps which of these would
be the correct answer in this scenario
it is C which is a cookie poisoning
attack because if you look at the steps
the attacker basically hijack the cookie
or stole the cookie and then modified it
to be utilized for some malicious
reasons
second question which one of the
following scanning techniques do
attackers use to bypass firewall rules
logging mechanisms and also hide
themselves as usual Network traffic a
stealth scanning technique B TCP connect
scanning technique C maintaining access
or D fin scanning technique now here as
you can understand we need to know what
these techniques are right so what does
a fin scan mean what is maintaining
access what is TCP connect what does TCP
mean tcp's transmission control protocol
how does it work so when you connect
using TCP what is actually happening in
the back end that is what the knowledge
is all about and in here the correct
answer is a stealth scanning technique
so what do we mean by stealth how can we
achieve that which tools help us achieve
that that is what we want to gain an
understanding in before we can attempt
the exam question three which of the
following Wi-Fi chalking method refers
to drawing symbols in public places to
advertise open wi-fi network War walking
War flying War chalking or War driving
now here we need to know first that
there is something known as Wi-Fi
chalking right and there are some
symbols that are utilized globally and
they recognized globally they're
standardized by the way and these
symbols represent some type of Wi-Fi
networks for example open wi-fi which
means you can freely connect to the
Wi-Fi or paid Wi-Fi where you have to
pay before you can connect to the Wi-Fi
or once you get connected you first to
have to make a payment only then the
internet would be activated right so for
different Wi-Fi mechanisms there are
different options that can be utilized
and which of the question is which of
the Wi-Fi chalking method refers to
drawing these symbols in public places
to advertise open wi-fi so in this the
answer is war chocking now the question
here itself is a little bit so here the
question itself is is a little bit
misleading because it mentions Wi-Fi
chalking in the question itself and that
would then lead us to whether War ch is
a correct answer or not so some of the
questions could be a little bit
misleading if you want to embark on a
successful career as a cyber security
professional then our postgraduate
program in cyber security the course
link is in the description box below now
let's talk about downloading and
installing KH Linux along with that
we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for Khali
Linux all right so I've opened my
browser and we want to go to the Kali
website so we want to go to kh.org you
can directly type in kh.org and go to
the website you can just do a Google
Search and say Ki download and it will
give you the same website but it will
directly take you to the downloads pages
so either here and or you can go to the
homepage uh cookies are being installed
on your machine so uh see which cookies
you want to allow I'm only going to use
the necessary cookies to support this
site and you can see that this gives you
the latest KH Linux news and tutorials
gives you the latest release what is in
that release and gives you a lot of
documentation which will help you
understand and what tools have been
developed and what functionality has
been given in the latest version if you
want to download you can directly go
here and you can download Ki Linux now
Ki Linux is a 2.6 gab download so it's
going to take time the latest version
being
2019.4 and we click over here I'm using
a download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and uh you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 GB download
so you click on download and the
background uh you can see this is going
to be downloaded and we going to
minimize this and uh it will take a few
minutes for that to download but this is
an ISO image so we need to install it on
a virtual machine so what we need is we
need to use a hypervisor which will
allow us to create virtual machines so
we can either use VMware Workstation
which you can download from here however
uh this is paid version so you can see
it is around $250 or something for uh
this software but it is a very good
software to have so if you click on
download now it is going to start the
download it's a 30-day trial period if
you want to use it after 30 days you'll
need to enter the key which you'll get
after purchasing the software if you do
not want to utilize this the free
version that you have you can either
download VMware Player but there are
some limitations for VMware Player that
you might want to look at does you want
to compare these products before you
want to purchase them right otherwise
you can download Oracle virtual box
which is a free hypervisor it's not as
robust as VMware Workstation but it does
the trick right so the the free version
uh 6.1 is free and you can then create
your own virtual machines over there and
install operating systems on them what I
do have I already have a VMware
Workstation installed so I'm just going
to open that up and that's my VMware
Workstation as you can see I already
have a lot of virtual machines created
over here what we going to do is we are
going to configure a virtual machine for
the Ki Linux operating system system
that we are downloading which should be
somewhere here let's see it's at 43% so
all halfway there till then let's create
the virtual machine so I C click on file
create a new virtual machine I'm going
to customize the machine so click on
next this L default we don't want to
change that and then we want to install
the operating system later we don't want
to point it out right now so I'll just
click on I will install the operating
system later click on next we want to
install Linux now in the drop down you
would not see Khali Linux next over here
however you can choose Ubuntu 64bit
that's what I'm going to choose there it
is next what is the name that we want I
want to give it KH Linux without the
typo and I want to store it in one of
the folders that I've created by default
it stores on the C drive which is not a
good place to store uh you don't want to
run out of space on your C drive so I'm
going to click on this PC and this is my
data and in here I'll have a folder
called virtual box or virtual machines
there it is within which you can see the
other softwares that I already created
I'm going to create a new folder and
call it Ki 2019 l l for his latest for
me because you can see already have a k
Linux so I'm just going to identify this
folder with the L at the end going to
select it and click on okay you can see
the path being changed over here click
on next it's going to ask you how many
processors now depending on the
processor that you have you can see I've
got a 8 core i7 so if I give it 16 cores
or 16 16 processors that's not going to
work I cannot go beyond what the
physicality already is so for this
machine One processor with one core is
more than enough if you're going to use
a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
you're given it two cores it will ask us
for Ram to be provided for this Virtual
Machine by default 248 mbytes that's 2
GB of RAM is more than enough if you
require more we can change this later on
so click on next we want to use Nat for
now leave the default next whatever is
recommended keep it the way it is we do
not want to change it next create a new
virtual hard disk for this machine and
it is going to ask us the size 20 GB is
more than fine store it as a single file
we don't want to use multiple file
options click on next and then click on
browse where we want to store the vmdk
file or the virtual hard disk file and
we go back again to the same folder that
we had created virtual machines and we
look at the Ki Linux Ki 2019 L and we
want we want to store the vmdk file over
there once we save it we want to click
on next and then we want to click on
finish so this is the virtual machine
that has been created right here right
now this is the basic configuration now
where are we at with the operating
system and you can see the operating uh
system has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so we
go to e Drive so we looking for the sub
the operating system that we have
downloaded we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the current one the KH
Linux
2019.4 ISO right here so what we do we
go back to the K Linux machine that we
have created edit virtual machine
settings and we point this virtual
machine using the CD DVD and then we
point the iso the one that we downloaded
over here so we go back to e Drive we go
back to OS and we click on KH Linx 2019
click on open so now when this boots up
it will boot up with this ISO and then
will it will allow us to install the
operating system so click on okay then
we click on on power on this virtual
machine it will start powering on it
will boot through the iso and it will
start giving us the booting options so
I'm just going to uh enter the full
screen mode over here for this to be
better visible and we don't want the
live mode what we want is we want to use
the graphical install and then we
highlight that we press enter and you
can see the setup starting up we'll wait
for the GUI to pop up there it is which
language do we want for now we want
English click on continue where are we
located click on continue
and the configure your keyboard we want
the US keyboard American English
continue it is going to detect the
hardware so as you can see on the screen
it's attempting uh Auto configuration
for most of these uh settings the
network with DHCP it has identified the
network cards uh Hardware like uh the
processor that has been provided now it
is asking for a host name we're going to
leave it at default we're going to click
on continue domain name I'm not joining
this into a domain as yet this is going
to to be a standalone machine so I can
leave this blank click on continue now
it is going to configure the network it
is asking for a password at this point
in time the root password type in any
password that you want ensure that you
remember the password now by default the
username for the account is the name is
the word root we are just creating the
password for the root account and then
we want to click on continue setting up
the clock looking at the Hard dis now
here it asks us do we want to use the
entire dis the 20gb virtual hard disk
that we had provided did or do we want
to give it a manual configuration or a
guided one where we want encryption and
a logical volume management coming into
the picture we just going to use the
first option guided you use entire disk
don't worry it's only going to use the
virtual disc that we had created click
on continue it will give us that it's a
21.5 GB VMware virtual disc that we had
and click on continue all files in one
partition that's what we want
recommended for new users whatever it is
we don't want to change these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured uh once we click on continue
it is going to say you are you sure you
want to make these changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing KH Linux on your device now
this is going to take a few minutes for
the installation to work all right so
that's the installation that's completed
now it's asking us to configure a
package manager a network mirror can be
used to supplement the software that is
included on the installation media this
may also make new versions of software
available do you want to use a network
mirror we can click no for now and then
click on continue now this is going to
install the GRUB boot loader this might
take a few minutes as well install the
group grub loader to the master boot
record yes click on continue click the
hard dis that you have just utilized
this is the one click on continue it
will install the graub boot loader
running through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and you you can see
this is starting up so we are going to
you you just wait out the boot and now
it started the booting sequence just
going to maximize the screen and you can
see it's asking me for the password this
is the one that we created now that's
the that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on log in
and this is your screen uh now what we
need to do here is we need to install
VMware tools which will help us manage
the screen and help the virtual machine
to be a a little bit better uh
integrated on the system so that's not
mounted yet so we're just waiting for it
to Mount there it is and what we want to
do here is open Vare tools of Creator
all right so what we want is we want to
extract or we want to use this open X
archival and once we do that we'll see
the VMware install. PL double click on
that all right we've got the VMware
tools here what I've done is we have
extract two and I've extracted that on
the desktop right so what we just did
was click on the desktop over here open
and this is what it will do and click on
extract now the error is happening
because I've already extracted this open
this up we want to run this VMware
install. PL so what do we do we open up
the terminal window which is the command
line interface over here and now this is
where some of the commands come into the
picture so for example PWD it will show
us the present working directory LS will
show us the list of the folders are
there so the folder that we have is on
our desktop so we'll just change
directory to desktop press enter do an
LS that will show us the list and you
can see VMware tools distrib that's the
folder that we have right here right so
we want to go into that folder CD VM
where at this point you can just click
on Tab and it will populate everything
over there press enter do an LS and we
want the VM where hyphen
install. PL to be executed all right so
we tried executing that command we had
an error over there so what we need to
do is we need to execute this command
so/ VMware hen install. PL and we'll
start creating now uh it will ask you
for your input installing VMware Tools
in which directory do you want to
install the binary files uh by default
it is going to use SL USR / bin if I
just press in uh enter it is going to
use the default as you can see the input
over here what directory do you want the
in directories I'm just going to press
uh keep on pressing enter for the
defaults to come in this part does not
exist it is going to create it default
yes defaults everywhere and then it
tries to start initializing it to
maximize the screen and this is where it
is installing and you can see by just
installing that it automatically
adjusted the screen and now we got a
full screen of K Linux right here right
and that is what VMware tools does for
us once we have installed the operating
system and now you can see the entire
screen on here you will will see the
tool sets that are given here now why
are we using K Linux in the first place
because this comes in uh with a bundle
of thousands of softwares that are ready
to be utilized for ethical hacking right
and they have been categorized over here
for information gathering vulnerability
analysis web application analysis and so
on so forth so you can see from forensic
onwards reporting tools and as you
scroll down you can see your development
tools Graphics coming in Internet uh and
the system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are right now the
favorites if I click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got Sparta nmap fuzzing
tools web application analysis we have
got comics Kip fish SQL map database
assessments password attacks and so on
so forth so if you just go in the
favorites this was the terminal emulator
that we utilize this the command line
that we saw we use the CD command we use
the PWD command command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list of
the directory that we are in similarly
there would be commands like cat so
let's go to CD downloads let's see what
the uh what's there you can see this
case sensitive so if I type in a capital
D and then do a tab LS there's nothing
over here on download so CD do dot will
take us back One Directory now you can
see we are back from downloads to root
if I want to go to desktop this is how I
go to desktop do a LS you can see the
VMware tools uh folder over there CD
VMware tools and we go into that folder
LS where will give us the list of all
those files now you can see install is a
file that we had edited back then so if
I do a cat install you will see the cat
basically is the command that will help
us look at the contents of the file all
right without opening of the file or
without editing the file so you can see
just uh if I scroll up this is where we
gave the cat command it then uh printed
the contents of the file over here and
then it exited and gave me back to
command line right here right now if I
want to copy this CP root desktop VMware
install and we want to copy it to root
downloads and press enter now what we
going to do is we going to see if this
file the install file that we just
edited over here has been C copied to
the downloads folder so we do us uh we
are currently in the VMware on the
desktop VMware tools District folder we
do a CD dot dot that takes us down one
directory so we are still in the desktop
do a CD dot dot now you can see we are
back in the rout and now we going to do
a CD downloads do an LS and you can see
the copied file right here so if I do a
cat install you can see the same content
of that file coming in so these are some
of the commands that we would need to
learn as we go ahead the remove command
is let's say we've got install we do a
man RM man is the manual page command
that uh gives us the pages with the
description of how that particular
command is to be utilized so RM is
remove files or directories synopsis the
description the options hyphen f for
Force hyphen I for prompt hyphen capital
I prompt once before removing more than
three files and so on so forth if you
want to exit this you can press Q to
exit and you come back to this page so
if I say RM install LS you'll see that
the install file has now been deleted so
in Windows we use the d d command in
Linux it is the RM command so this is
what we wanted to look at the demo for K
Linux how to download it how to install
it and some of the basic commands that
we can
utilize python is a computer programming
language often used to build websites
and software it can also be used to
automate tasks and conduct data
analysis python is a general purpose
language meaning it can be used to
create a variety of different programs
and isn't specialized for any specific
problem this versatility along with its
beginner friendliness has made it one of
the most used programming languages
today a survey conducted by industry
analyst firm Redmon found that it was
the most popular programming languages
among developers in
2020 python is commonly used for
developing websites and software task
automation data analysis and data
visualization since it's relatively easy
to Learn Python has been adopted by many
non-programmers such as accountants and
scientists for a variety of everyday
tasks like organizing finances it has
become a staple in data science allowing
data analysts and other professionals to
use the language to conduct complex
statistical calculations creating data
visualizations build machine learning
algorithms manipulate and analyze data
and complete other data related
tasks python however is mostly used to
create scripts rather than full scale
programs a python script the file
containing the commands is structured to
be executed like a program these files
are designed to contain various
functions and import various modules
python interactive shell or the
respective command line is used to
execute the script to perform a specific
task a script is structured by defining
the set of function definitions and then
stating the main program used to call
the functions a program consists of
numerous tasks these tasks can be
executed with the help of scripts unlike
libraries scripts can be used without
importing and are less code
intensive
python variable assignment is different
from some of the popular languages there
is no Declaration of a variable just an
assignment statement when we declare a
variable in C or C++ or any other alike
languages this sets aside an area of
memory for holding values allotted by
the data type of the variable the memory
allocated will be interpreted as the
data type suggests at compile time
initial value will be checked so we
cannot mix the data types in between but
python is a dynamically typed language
it doesn't know about the type of the
variable until the code is run so the
Declaration is of no use what it does is
it stores that value at some memory
location and then binds the variable
name to that memory container this makes
the contents of the container accessible
through that variable name so the data
type does not matter it will get to know
the type of the value during
runtime python also offers multiple
options for developing GUI or graphical
user interface out of all the G methods
teiner is the most commonly used method
it is a standard python interface to the
TK GUI toolkit shipped with python
python with T is the fastest and easiest
way to create GUI
applications Python programming
languages is widely used by companies
around the world to build web apps
analyze data automate operations via
devops and create reliable scalable
Enterprise applications many companies
do not even realize they are using
python across their organization ations
for example if a company is a Java only
company but they use ibmf sphere as a
web application server then they have to
use Python to script the server
configuration python has a habit of
getting in everywhere regardless of
whether the usage is intentional big
names like Microsoft Netflix Google Uber
and Dropbox regularly use python in
their software framework
development now that we understand
Python's basic functionality let's cover
some of its advantageous when compared
to Industry
counterparts when it comes to third
party modules the python package index
also known as pypi contains several
thirdparty modules that allow python to
communicate with the majority of other
languages and system it has functions
that are separate to the python code
base and has many extra capabilities
that can be activated later
on python also contains a vast standard
library that covers topics such as test
string operations internet protocols web
services tools and OSI
interfaces many joint programming tasks
have already been coded into the
standard Library considerably reducing
the amount of code that a new developer
must
write python is open source due to a
lack of official technical support which
has driven the establishment of
communities that increase the Resource
Bank for the language's continuing
growth and acceptance its source score
development is partnered with multiple
coders and receives Community feedback
with well features are often shared with
the community to Garner feedback before
pushing them onto the main
branch python includes built-in data
structures such as lists and
dictionaries that may be used to create
quick runtime data structures
furthermore python has added benefit of
dynamic high level data typing
decreasing the support code length
required data structures are the set of
data elements that produced a well
organized way of storing and organizing
the data in the computer so that it can
be usedful
for example the data structures like
stack Q Link list Etc are mostly used in
the field of computer science artificial
intelligence and Graphics
Etc we have now covered all the features
python offers and the basic
functionalities let's write some
realtime python code that can crack
passwords using Python's
libraries in this demo we will write two
blocks of code both of which offer a
unique way to break passwords the first
one is a Brute Force attack the other is
a dictionary attack the difference with
Brute Force attack is that in brute
force a large number of possible key
permutations are checked whereas in the
dictionary attack only the words with
the most possibilities of success are
checked and are less time consuming than
Brute Force so let's jump into the code
editor
now the code editor we are using today
is
pycharm pycharm serves as an ID for
running Python program specifically and
can be downloaded for free as a Comm
Community
addition now the first thing we're going
to start is by importing some libraries
the first one would be the random
Library this one would be necessary to
generate the random choices from which
the password will be
guessed next we're going to import
another Library known as py Auto
GUI
this is necessary to generate a
graphical user interface where the user
will be asked to enter the password to
be
cracked next we're going to create a
variable called
as
C this will hold the number of
characters it will store all the
characters which can be used in our
password so we're going to start with
all the alphabets
and just to be safe we're going to add
all the digits as well from 0 to 9 now
this can be expanded further to include
special characters but we're going to
skip that for this
example next we're going to turn this
variable into a list this is necessary
so that we can Traverse the list
accordingly so we're going to create a
new variable All Care and convert this
into a
list and there we
go regarding the user they are asked to
enter a password that needs to be
cracked the password will be entered
into a graphical user interface and can
be stored in a
variable let's take it as
PWD we're going to use the py auto G
function to generate the GUI the type of
input will be a password input so that
the values entered are not
visible you're going to write a message
such as enter a
password and that's it let skip the
semicolon over
here the user will see this message on
the graphical user interface and can
then enter a password now the passwords
that are being guessed need to be stored
somewhere so we're going to create a
sample PWD password and just enter a
null value to go
with now we're going to start generating
random values that need to be checked
for that we're going to use a while
loop and the condition that we're going
to run is sample password which will be
our guest password should not be equal
to PWD which is the original password
now this Loop will run as long as the
values are not same the moment the
sample password which is a password
guessed and generated randomly becomes
equal to the original password this Loop
will be closed and the program will be
over so we're going to start generating
by assigning the value of sample PWD is
equal to going to use the random.
choices
function and the arguments we're going
to pass as all capap which is the list
of all the values that need to be
checked or more like all the characters
that can be used to Generate random
choices and for the length if we're
going to assign a value of K which will
be the length of the original password
the original password which is entered
we're going to check the length using
the Leen function and make sure that the
random choices function generates
passwords of that lens specifically now
we can skip this so that it checks for
all the possible variations and and all
the different length but that will take
time so we're going to stick with
something small for this
example next we're going to print out a
message where we can see the number of
values that are being checked we can put
up a simple
message such as
this we're going to check the string
value of sample
PWD and we're going to close the message
that's
it now this is the one that generates
the random choices we also have to check
the choices with the original password
so we're going to set up an if condition
over here and we're going to write if
sample PWD is the same as PWD or we have
to use the list version of PWD since
sample PWD in itself will be a
list if it is true we're going to print
the
password
is going to put up a
space and we're going to
join the new
one this will display the guest password
we can break over here so that we run
out of the if condition and the loop now
let's run this code
once to run
mean okay as you can see we have missed
a colon sign over here in the while
function so we're going to run it
now as you you can see we have the GUI
that is asking the password for us now
we can give a small password so that we
can see if it's working or not we're
going to
write PC2 and since we have given the
data being input as do password it's not
going to show what is being entered over
here I have entered the password of a
bc1 so press okay and you can see it's
going to check the combinations of four
digit passwords now this doesn't follow
a specific order so this works on
generating random choices we can create
programs that goes a specific order as a
single permutation like we're going to
start from 00 and move on to 00001
that's typically how normally Brute
Force password crackers work but this is
easier to examine and we can see how the
program is being worked on using
this now if we going to stop it for
now and give it another try going to run
Main
I'm going to try something else and you
can see it keeps running up the same
program and this time I ends enter the
password of abc2 and you can see in one
of those random choices it did find out
my password like I said we can do this
using a systematic method where it goes
from the first option to the very last
one but this is more easier to explain
and more easier to visualize as a first
program now regarding our next program
which is going to be a dictionary attack
a dictionary attack uses a word list a
word list will cons will have a list of
passwords that can be used or a list of
possible outcomes we're going to start
by importing some libraries on its own
here we need to use only import
hashlib because the password that we
going to enter will be a hash version
we're not going to give the plain text
password in an input like we did in the
previous program so to work on those
those hash and the functions that are
necessary to work on those hashes we're
going to use this Library we're also
going to set up a
counter of pass
found this is necessary to know if the
password has been found or not when we
do find the right password we can change
the value of this counter and the
program and The Interpreter will know
that our program has been
completed the password that the user
will enter needs to be in a hash format
so we're going to keep it in a variable
known as let's say I hash we're going to
ask the user for the
input enter the hashed
password and there we go next we're
going to use the word list over here to
use the word list we need to open it how
can we do that let's take up a variable
known as P
doc we're going to ask the user for an
input going to move on to the next line
using the back sln command and write
enter password file name including
path so what we are asking over here is
we're going to ask the user for a
particular path in the local system
where the file has been opened
up once the user gives the file name
path we can open it and store it in a
file let's say p
file and we going to use the file option
functionalities of python
okay functionalities of python we're
going to use the path stored in P do and
open in read mode
only next we're going to set up our Loop
which is going to check every single
password with the hash password we're
going to use a for loop we're going to
carry out every word in the open file
over
here next as we know we have received a
hashed value of the password we need to
convert it into standard terms before we
can start
comparing first what we have to do is we
have to encode the hashed password into
a common variable known as the utf8
standard now there's a good chance that
It Is by default in utf8 and coding but
the running this line helps us in being
sure that the next few lines work
correctly we're going to store another
variable known as hash word this is
after the encoding where we're going to
use another hash Li function which is
the
md5 so that we can convert the
value found in ENC
word
and keep it in a hashed format now that
you have made it clear that we now the
hash can be read and run by the computer
we're going to get the final hash digest
of it now to strip the hash digest we're
going to store it in a value let's say
of name
digest we use the value generated above
in
hashw and write hex Digest
this will generate the hash digest of
the password and create store it in this
digest variable now we have the digest
so we can start comparing it to the
password file that we have found we're
going to write a loop such as if digest
is equal to the input hash which is the
hash password that the user
input then we can just
print
password
found which we can then show using
whatever value has been extracted right
now from the password file or the word
list we also going to change the
variable of the past found counter to
one and we're going to
break now let's say that we do not find
a
password we have to inform the user that
the password is not found in the
particular word list so we're going to
write another loop let's say if not pass
found now think of it from a systematic
way the default value of pass found is
zero let's say we do find a password in
the word list the value is getting
changed to one so at this point of time
the value of pass found should be one if
the password has been found if not one
which basically implies if zero since
one is considered as true and zero is
considered as false if it is one this
part of the if condition will not be
executed this part will only be executed
if no password is found and by default
the value of pass found is zero so if
not zero we'll turn to if one which is
supposed to be true and the following
lens will be executed so the next few
lines we're going to print that the
password was not
found and we can start running the
program now to generate the hashed
password we're going to use an online
tool on as the md5 generator.com now
let's say our user password is the same
as is the one we used in the last
program which is
abc2 we're going to generate the hash
we're going to copy the md5 ash over
here we press on copy and we're going to
paste crl V and press enter now this
password file name is asking for the
location of the word list now I have
stored the word list in my D drive with
the name of p1. dxt this file has a list
of passwords which also include the word
abc2 in there so go to press enter as
you can see it has found the password
abc2 after doing the hash
functionalities over
here now if we were to remove it let's
say we're going to use a wrong password
for example we're going to create a new
value such as of ABC
5 and take this new hash
value we're going to rerun this program
and we're going to use a new hash hash
value which is not present in the
current word
list as you can see we are now getting
the expected password notb
functionality so this way the password
has been cracked open with two different
types of attacks using a brute force and
a dictionary attack since this type of
methodology works on a word list this is
known as a dictionary attack as it has a
source of passwords where it can check
the POS I outcomes
from let's begin with the fishing uh
tutorial we have the khanx operating
system booted up over here uh what we
going to do is we going to open up a
tool called SE social engineering
toolkit which you would find in this
option and that's the tool that we want
it's a command line tool uh a menu
driven tool we are going to host a fake
uh Facebook page and we can see how we
can Harvest credentials by this kind of
an attack so these are some disclaimers
you might want to go through that do you
want to agree to the terms of service
yes press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a fishing attack which comes under
the social engineering attack so like I
said it's a menu driven tool so we just
have to look at these options and then
just type in the number of the option
that we want so we want to do a social
engineering attack so I type in one
press enter and that it is asking me
whether I want a spear fishing attack a
website attack Vector we going to choose
a second option so I type in two press
enter and then it asks me uh what I want
to do I want to take the third option
here credential Harvester attack
methodology and we want to do the third
attack now it is asking whether we want
to use the inhouse website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool if you're
going to do the site cloning option so
we going to type in two press enter and
then it is going to ask me the IP
address where it wants to capture and
store the credentials by default this is
the IP address that I'm using so if I
leave it blank it will take my default
IP address so I'm just going to press
enter and now it is asking me the URL to
clone so I type in
HTTPS dubdub dub.
facebook.com what it is going to do it
is going to connect online and it is now
you just it has cloned the website
Facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that if use the if the
username and password form are in the
same field or the same page regardless
this captures all posts on a website so
you may need to copy tub dub dub star
into HTML depending on where your
directory structure is PR return if you
understand what we are saying here so
press enter the social engine toolkit
credential Harvest attack is running on
Port 80 information will be displayed to
you as it arrives so the site was
71134 right the default IP address and
this is where the website is being
hosted let's check that out so let me
open up a browser on my host machine and
uh let me point it to the K Linux
machine that we have just created 192
71134 and you should see a log to
Facebook coming up right here looks
genuine it is genuine because we just
went online and downloaded this let's
just have a recap let's have an
explanation of what we are trying to do
I am trying to host fake Facebook page
on my server which has an embedded
script in it which is going to do
credential harvesting so the attack here
is let's say if I now hosted this I can
craft a fake email send it across to a
victim saying uh your Facebook account
has seen some unforeseen activity create
a hyperlink using HTML coding within
that click here to access your account
and verify uh that the account is
secured and when they click on that link
they will be redirected to my fake page
which is here you can see the uh IP
addresses my virtual machines IP address
but I'm seeing a Facebook login page and
I'm going to type in someone at
somewhere. comom and the password I'm
just going to type in the regular ones
that I use and if you see it when we
typed in uh the username and password
the page just refreshed and give us the
login page again but now if you look at
the URL I'm actually on Facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that I
was hosting so a lman wouldn't probably
figure out they've been hacked by now
they just would figure out okay they
probably typed in the incorrect password
and the page refresh or something like
that and they're just going to log in
and they're actually going to access the
Facebook page thus they might not even
realize that something went wrong but if
I go back to my virtual machine you can
see that it has captured some data and
it is reporting over here of what has
happened so if I just scroll up let's
see what happened here and if we have
been able to capture anything so we got
a hit printing the output this does the
HTTP 1.12 200 okay response coming in
password field found and and we just
looking there it is email someone
some.com and uh password that I typed in
ASD at theate 1 2 3 4 so it has captured
the username and the password right here
uh once we done I mean this is the way
attackers work now this is a very basic
attack again uh in the actual trainings
you would then look at how you would
Host this on a real website make it a
global attack right now it's a virtual
machine with a Class C IP address so
here the thought processes where and we
get a free hosting where we can host
this kind of sites maybe I'll have to
purchase a domain which looks like
similar to Facebook or the victim that
I'm trying to attack so this is just a
POC so we just wanted to find out if we
can how fishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done right so pressing
contr C would exit this tool and takes
you back to the actual menu press 99 99
to exit and there it is close the two
window and that's the fishing practic
after fishing let's talk about SQL
injection SQL injection stands for a
structured query language injection
which is a database attack though it
resides within the application so it's
the application avability that we trying
to uh look at to try to bypass
authentication as the name suggest a SQL
injection will liity allows an attacker
to inject malicious input into a SQL
statement what is a SQL statement a
query that is used by an application and
is fired off to the database database
executes that query uh gets that uh
information that is required and sends
it back to the user if the user is
authenticated so we're going to look at
the SQL injection attack demo here and
uh what we are going to do is we're
going to go back to our vmw workstation
and I've got a tool over here called
ovas broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we going
to see if we can create a SQL injection
attack just waiting for it to boot up
once it boots up it will give us an IP
address there we are so we need to
connect to 71. 132 so I can just use the
same browser I was using close of
Facebook and now go to 192
16871 132 and this is the oasp broken
web application project uh what we're
going to do is we going to go to mutil
day and this is a application that has a
lot of information within it you can see
it gives you links about what you should
do help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now I'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in I'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create
create a query now what does a query
look like when I type in a username and
a password if I just type in a single
quote here it is going to create an
error and this is what a SQL query looks
like select username from account where
username is a single quote and then the
exception error happened so it it's not
showing the rest of the query to us what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
craft a query here uh single quote and
give it a condition or 1 equal 1 space
hyphen hyphen space What Happens hyphen
hyen space is comments out anything
after that so the password field is
being commented out at this point in
time and I'm just giving it a condition
where the condition is true one does
equal one and if this condition is true
it is going to allow me to log in so you
can see right now we not logged in this
bypasses the authentication mechanism
and you can see user authenticated and
we are now logged in as admin so uh in
the training what we need to understand
uh as a whole is how SQL Works what are
the queries that are structured with how
you can what are the testing operators
now the single quote that we used that
was an operator in the SQL syntax what
these operators are how they function
and then how we can leverage these
attacks there are different tools that
are given to you in Khali as well that
uh you can utilize so in Khali Linux you
can just open up a command prompt and
there's a tool called SQL map you need
to give it a particular site so SQL map
hyphen U for the URL and whatever the
URL is now URL here and then once you're
here we just press the enter key this
tool will craft all the queries in the
background for you you don't even have
to no SQL query or SQL languages uh this
is a very easy tool to utilize sadly I
cannot demo this on a live website
because that would be illegal but uh you
can uh see how you can operate this
yourself that's what uh SQL injections
are all about moving on we now talk
about uh vpn's virtual private networks
and a virtual private network is
basically a secure network that allows
me to to anonymize myself over the
Internet so what I'm doing is I'm
connecting from here to a server that
encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and does allows me to keep my
data secure now the basic essense of a
VPN or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
I can encrypt and Safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a VPN
gives is that you can allow us to spoof
our IP address or officiate our IP
address so we can actually become
Anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple IP addresses and thus
uh secure ourself on the internet for
example I use VPN called cyber ghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here if you look
at the entire list all the servers then
there are no spy servers uh which and
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that I'm doing right since they
located out of Romania this becomes a
little bit more safer for me because the
government and the laws over there are a
little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me uh different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection feature so uh there are a lot
of vpns out there so for example let's
go to the website cyber host.com so we
can see there's a a sale going on 76%
sale or you can go on to
expressvpn which is also a very good VPN
then there is nordvpn it depends on what
uh you want and and how you want to
utilize it so just purchasing a VPN or
getting a free three VPN is not enough
it depends on which country the VPN
originates from and which server you're
connected to for example most of the
countries uh have a PCT where they share
information amongst themselves even if
you're connected to a VPN that means
that these companies that provide these
Services have to generate and store logs
and these logs have to be reported to
the government if they ask for it now if
uh there's a list of 14 countries that
actually focuses on this practice so you
have to find out VPN that and a server
that is not a part of those 14 countries
and ensure that those logs are not going
to be reported to the uh government and
these are three vpns basically are
something that which are good and I
personally use cyber ghost I've used the
others I just keep on rotating them just
to get an idea of which one is better so
uh these are vpns that can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there other safer VPN hide
my ass expressvpn and so on so forth
from our terminologies let's now talk
about VPS uh VPS is basically virtual
private server where you can rent a
service or server as a service a virtual
machine as a service so basically on a
cloud using infrastructure as a service
you can rent a server and utilize it for
whatever activity you want so let's go
to uh these sites register.com go to ID
Network Solutions or we can talk about
other Cloud Solutions as well so here
you can get register your domain names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about the fishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the O's I'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the Facebook
and see let's see if uh anything of that
is available now something. is available
or face tips.com is available uh there
are other options that are making over
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting uh with a web hosting as
a service and uh we can have a Linux
based uh hosting or a Windows based
hosting depending on what you want and
that's where your shared hosting comes
into the picture if you just want uh if
you want to look at a virtual server and
you want to rent a server over there
it's itself you can move on to
rackspace.com and here in your services
you can have physical server or a
virtual server in a public Cloud your
other Cloud providers uh for example
would be Amazon AWS and on AWS you can
basically look at ec2 elastic compute
Cloud which is basically virtual servers
in the cloud and over here you can rent
out a server with whatever capacity you
require you'll obviously have to pay the
rent for what what those servers are
going to cost but once you have those
servers you can then launch any services
on top of it uh looking at uh other
services that we have we talked about t
t is a onion routing uh software that
allows users to browse the web
anonymously so we can just go online and
we can try to spoof our identity and I'm
going to show you how so I've got a vmw
workstation right here the one so we're
just going to pull that up and we going
to power on a Windows 7 machine where we
going to look at the onion routing so
Windows machine has booted up we just
going to to log in and uh this is my
Windows 7 machine now I've got a Chrome
browser right here and we're going to go
to a website called C myip.com which is
going to give the IP address that I'm
currently using so right now I'm not on
connected to any VPN or anything and you
can see that's my IP address that I'm
utilizing now if I want to anonymize
myself what I'm going to do is I am
going to uh use T and that's the tower
browser that's set up right there if I
click on it it's going to open up the
software and it's going to create a new
n Network and it's going to connect to
the to network and allow me to anonymize
myself all right so that's the to
browser opening up and uh giving me a
new browser over here so I've got one
which is the old one which is uh my
current IP address if I just refresh
that you'll see that I am still on the
same IP address as far as this browser
is concerned there's a refresh and it's
still showing me the same IP address
where if I go on to to right now and if
I go to C myip.com you will see that it
is going to give me and you can see the
amount of time with is taking to reach
that site that's because I am using a
VPN and there's a lot of encryption
running off and you can see now I'm sing
uh connected via Hong Kong and even to
reach this site what Tor does is it
gives me a proxy chain a proxy chain is
where it creates multiple hops to hide
my identity and uh before I reach see my
uh ip.com I am using three different IP
addresses over here one in France one in
Germany and one in Hong Kong so if I do
something over here to trade back my
steps to my actual IP address the law
enforcement agencies or anyone who's
going to search uh like a forensic
investigator would have to go through
these IP addresses before they come back
to me now it's not impossible but the
effort and time that's going to be taken
to come across three different countries
is going to uh be phenomenal so it may
just defeat the purpose of having so
much resources spent to identify who did
what so that's what T does for us all
right moving on from Tor we are going to
look at Key loog loers key loggers are
basically softwares that run in the
background and record all the key
strokes of the user so if I've got a key
logger installed right now whatever I
type will be stored in a text file for
the hacker so that they can look at it
later on and just to give you an example
of that we go back to my VMware
Workstation and we open up another
Windows 7 machine I'm going to power
this on and I'm going to close this one
to then so this virtual machine has
booted up we are going to use user One
login as user one let's close all these
softwares uh which are not required and
once this machine is booted up what
we're going to do is I'm just going to
open up a random websites and see what
we're doing basically there's a key
logger that's there in the startup
that's going to record our key strokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now Firefox is getting updated so
let's hold on now this is the latest
version of Firefox right and we just
going to go to let's say
facebook.com wait for the website to
open up all right let's try opening it
up again and that's facebook.com and
we're just going to type in some random
username and password somewhere someone
at somewhere. comom and the password
being again ASD atate 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 90
login obviously that login is not going
to work user probably doesn't exist or
if it does the password probably is
incorrect and uh so we going to close
this uh we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh
rediff.com and then go to Redi mail try
the same thing over here someone at
somewhere. comom password is d 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 whatever it is don't say you can see
the combination is incorrect now there's
a key logger running in the background
and what we want is we now want to open
up the key logger now it is visible here
because I've kept it visible you can
hide it in the start menu and there's a
shortcut key for you to pull it up later
on so this completely becomes invisible
and uh what it can do is it basically
creates a record of whatever you have
been doing so far so you can see these
things populating on the 25th of
December so if I look at the visited
websites you can see I opened up Mozilla
Firefox the first where it uh there was
a problem loading the page then we
opened up Facebook then we opened up
rediffmail.com and so on so forth so
this it just gives me the list of
visited websites whereas if I look at
keystrokes and clipboard you will see
whatever VI have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again uh the
second time I try try to type in then uh
I hit backspace then I typed in
facebook.com and then you can see I
typed in someone at some.com and in tab
ASD at 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 we closed up
the browser we opened up a new one and
we went on to rediffmail.com and then
you can see me typing this one then
going back one space then the rest of
what I typed and then the password
coming in so that's what a key logger
does if you look at the taskbar it's not
going to show you a key logger running
in the background it's in processes
you're not going to see anything at all
but it's going to mask itself as a
service so if you look into the
properties you can see that icon coming
in over here which matches this one and
so you can see that this masking itself
as a service.exe if this gets hidden as
well it would be very difficult for a
user to even identify this all right so
that's what a key logger is moving on
let's see what else we want to talk
about so we talk about t we have talked
about key loggers and now we want to
talk about firewalls now for key loggers
to be prevented we need antiviruses
right so we know need a good antivirus
program that's going to be installed
updated and run on a regular basis to
protect ourselves from malware but what
about network connections and you need a
firewall in a system to prevent or to
detect what kind of connections are
going on in the first place now we
cannot rely on software is 100% so even
if a firewall is not configured properly
it's that's going to be a problem so
what we we need to do is we have to have
a firewall configure it correctly and
then allow and this allow certain
activity from off uh happening and what
we're going to do is I've got such a
system on my machine here I use a
software called glass wire what it does
is it is a network analyzer so it allows
me to analyze whatever is going on you
can see all the apps that I'm utilizing
and how much upload and download they
have been uh doing all the traffic so
you can see the protocols that I'm
utilizing so I come to know what's going
on in the background and this gives me
the entire graph of how much I have been
doing for the past 24 hours past 3 hours
past 5 minutes and so on so forth right
so this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating I can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
I have utilized since I've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
hosts have been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that I have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and I can just
click on a particular service to lock
that service so this becomes a discovery
tool identifies whatever networking is
going on gives me all that information
and then I can look at and I can just
click on any of these services that I
find it as malicious and block them I
can create different profiles for
different applications as I'm as when I
want them and these are the alerts so
you can see that this was the first time
a network connection was looked at from
VMware and what this allows me to do is
whenever I execute a file it can upload
it to virustotal.com and scan it as a
third party antivirus to ensure that
there is nothing malicious on it so I
already have an antivirus over here but
if this ever gets compromised I still
can rely on a third party service where
in real time as and when I execute my
applications uh they would be verified
and I would be assured that nothing is
wrong with my system and this software
that I'm utilizing glass wire basic is
free and then there are paid versions as
well it's just glass wire.com is where
you're going to find this moving on root
kit root kits are also malicious
softwares that you allow an unauthorized
user to have access to a computer to
restrict areas of its software now a
rootkit in is ense is which a software a
malicious software that infects a
machine and prevents aun some
functionality from it like hiding data
or preventing users from uh running
antiviruses and uh it's basically a
malicious software that is used to hide
information from the victim so that they
would not realize that they have
actually been compromised it's going to
be a difficult showing of a root kit so
I cannot show that demo to you so we
just going to move on and we are going
to talk about ethical hacking techniques
now now when we say ethical hacking
techniques we want to look at what kind
of audits are available when we want to
do ethical hacking so uh there's a
blackbox audit a white box audit and a
gray box audit so if I'm invited in an
organization to conduct a test to cond
conduct a audit to conduct a
vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they're going to give me three
different variations in a blackbox audit
they're not going to tell me about the
infrastructure they're not going to give
me any information and they want me to
start from the basics of gathering
information identifying the systems and
based on the information that I gather
whether I'm able to develop any hacks
and get compromise their infrastructure
so it will be a simulation of a hacker
who's sitting outside the organization
and trying to find a way in whereas a
white box audit is where full
infrastructure knowledge is given
anything and everything that is required
for an audit is given and this is a
simulation of an Insider attack a person
sitting inside the organization misusing
their permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to so the
simulation is from a malicious Insider a
gray box is where some partial knowledge
is available and from that partial
knowledge you're going to try to build
up more information and then you're
going to try to get access to those
resources what are the tools that we
utilize so we've already had a couple of
demos on key loggers SQL injection SQL
map and so on so forth Metasploit is a
very much used tool for penetration
testing and uh having knowledge on
Metasploit is very much necessary as far
as ethical hacking is concerned nmap
this is a tool used for network
discovery NS a varability scanner y
shock is a packet capturer that allows
you to capture packets and analyze
whatever is going on on SQL map is
something that we have seen a SQL
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and John the Ripper is a
password cracking Tool uh backtrack used
to be an operating system that was
utilized for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called Kali Linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos where we try
to look at SQL map and those injection
attacks that we did so what are the
areas of ethical hacking we have just
talked about all these areas as well
Network Serv Services we looked at the
glass Wire application that showed us
how my machine is consuming networks
which Protocols are being consumed how
the connections are being uh created if
somebody's able to install a troan on my
machine it is going to try to create a
new connection on the network with the
hacker to allow that hacker a back door
access now if I have that glass wire or
a similar firewall implemented it is
this wire wall that is going to detect
it and prevent that connection from
happening so if I install a software
that that is suddenly suspicious or that
install something else in the background
that I may not be aware of that tool is
going to identify all the connections
that are being made and it is going to
highlight that connection I need to go
through all of those connections and
identify whether they are legit or not
and if I find some suspicious or
doubtful I'm going to block that
connection and then I'm going to
investigate what's going on and that's
where ethical hacking comes into the
picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or uh if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some SQL
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a avability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access uh
to resources that we were not authorized
for and then client side attacks would
be where uh you install key logger at
the end of the at the client system and
then you try to capture whatever data
the uh user is typing in like username
and passwords on the Facebook and the
rediffmail.com website that we saw and
then try to misuse that information to
get access to those resources then Wi-Fi
networks right Wi-Fi is something that
we use on a regular basis we got our
smart devices nowadays smartphones
tablets faets that we can connect to
Wi-Fi and start using all our services
our banking applications and our
smartphones and thus we want to ensure
that wireless connectivity is simple and
is secured so you want to use encryption
mechanisms you want to use tools on your
smart phones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you are utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the fishing website on
facebook.com we've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and uh host them on
aache server so if you look at it as a
from ethical Hacker's perspective the
job of ethical hacker is to simulate
these kind of attacks that a hacker May
conduct and uh first of all you're
basically going to find out areas where
these attacks can happen think of it
from a hacker's perspective try to
simulate those attacks and see if those
attacks are going to be effective can
those attacks be prevented and can your
current security controls that you have
put in place identify detect and prevent
these attacks from happening in the
first place and that is what ethical
hacking is all about if you want to
embark on a successful career as a cyber
security professional then have a
postgraduate program in cyber security
the course link is in the description
box below ethical hacking if you have
never used Linux before and are looking
to get into it it this is the perfect
opportunity for you to learn on how you
can use this operating system in your
daily lives now although this video is
specifically ker towards people who are
trying to get into cyber security or who
are trying to learn ethical hacking the
more people that get into Linux is that
much easier because it just provides an
alternative operating system that you
can use and perform in your day-to-day
lives now uh it's very important
especially for ethical hackers to
understand how linox works and
specifically how K linox works that we
are going to cover today now as K Linux
is also an operating system dedicated
specifically to cyber security analysts
and hackers and has a bunch of tools
that makes the process of ethical
hacking and vulnerability analysis
malware analysis very easy so uh in this
Linux crash course we will learn
everything about K Linux what it is what
you can use it for then understanding a
bit more of the Linux system
fundamentals now now that can span
across a multip a variety of topics for
the uh Linux fundamentals we often have
how to navigate the file system how we
can use the Linux operating system
command terminal for creating editing
and just manipulating files we'll
understand some networking commands that
can help you we'll understand the uh the
service mechanism how to start St start
Services stop Services we'll understand
how to install uninstall some particular
tools will also create a small script
with bash so that you can understand how
you can use the bash language to start
your scripting journey in K Linux
directly before we move forward let's
check out the CH certification course by
simply learn if you want to learn more
about cyber security and ethical hacking
in general check out our C certification
training course the certified ethical
hacker certification is the industry
standard for train penetration testers
and our training program will ensure you
are well equipped with all the necessary
skills and techniques required to Ace
the exam you'll get an exam voucher for
free with the course allowing you to
learn master and Excel as a penetration
tester with a single package you can
find the link for the course in the
description box below that being said we
can get started with our demonstration
now the first thing we need to
understand is how we can install Linux
properly to install Linux or k Linux to
be specific in this case we will need
two things one we need the ISO file
which is basically the installation file
of every single operating system and we
will need an environment to run it in
now many people um use Linux or any
other operating system as a dual boot in
the system so that when you start up
your computer or a laptop it will ask
you where do you want to boot into do
you want to boot into Windows or k or
ubu something like that but for easier
access what many people prefer and many
people will recommend is using a
virtualization software so what that
will happen is you will keep using your
normal Windows operating system but you
can use virtualization software like
virtual box or VMware to run Linux
operating systems in Windows directly it
will uh run in a sandboxed environment
which makes it easier to learn and you
don't have to dedicate another uh boot
loer access and it just gets a whole lot
complicated dual booting is a lot more
complicated and it is recommend it is is
recommended for beginners to just stick
with virtualization software now for
virtualization software you will get two
options here which will be virtual Box
by Oracle or
VMware now I highly recommend
VMware because I feel it is much more
stable and it has a a bit more fluidity
when learning operating systems now
since you are running full-fledged
operating systems in a single window
your system must have a good amount
amount of ram free so that it can be
completely dedicated to the operating
system being run in that sandbox
environment so I would really recommend
uh VMware over virtual box which I feel
is has become slightly dated now
meanwhile VMware Workstation player is
going to be much better this is
obviously a a case of preference and you
can try out virtual box if you want most
of the things will be similar but once
you download VMware and install
it you should be getting a window like
this now this is the works workstation
you can get the VMR Player version which
is the free version you can get that as
well and again most of the things will
be similar so now that we have VMware
and we have our environment where we are
going to install Linux and work on it
let's check Ki Linux now K Linux as you
can see it's the world's most advanced
penetration testing distribution and
more importantly it is based on Debian
Debian is one of the uh you can say that
the forefathers of operating systems one
of the operating systems which paved the
way for many Linux distributions to be
based on it apart from Kali we also have
another operating system which is called
parot security this is also uh used by
ethical hackers and cyber security
analyst because this has the uh this
functions the same way as SC Linux as in
it has all the tools and techniques that
you may require in your ethical hacking
Journey so you can use either of them
either K Linux or pirate security and
more importantly for today's video
actually any Linux distribution will do
because this is more about learning the
basics and the basics will stay same
irrespective if you go for Kali parat
Ubunto or any other L division that you
can think of but um just letting you
know that there are two options here
Barett has a bit more features but K
Linux is the industry standard today and
has been for like a decade now at this
point uh so it is much recommended to go
with Kali and that's what we are going
to work on today so to download the ISO
file we'll just click the download
button
here and you can see it offers a variety
of options you can directly download for
virtual machines which is see as you can
see it is the recommended but it is it
is going to deprive you of a
few um learning things so what we can do
is we will get the live boot system what
liveo will do it will provide the ISO
file which we can later use to install
on our VM system so I will go to the
live
boot includes
everything as you can see I got a
torrent
file I will place this torrent for
download
now actually instead of the torrent we
can just download the point release live
image um this actually this version had
every tool possible but this one this uh
January Edition you can see Kali 20 23.1
the January live version Point release
live image you can just download this
one directly just click the download
button here which is written at 3.8 GS
the ISO file size just click on download
and your download will start remember
once again you can do this process with
parot security directly as well I think
if you go to download button here yes
you have to choose a security Edition
now they also have multiple versions for
let's say the home edition is for daily
use you know um just casual browsing or
just U multimedia process all those
things hack the box is completely
separate U service that functions easy
to easy to hack um boxes that will be a
completely separate Edition similar to
Cloud architect and Raspberry Pi but if
you are going to use parro security get
the security addition directly L just
download it from here and you it you'll
be good to go but for now we are just
going to install khux since that is what
the majority of Industry uses and we'll
move forward with it
again these are the
containers yes now what what would have
happened if you had chosen virtual
machine is as you can see there are many
virtualization software like the dware
virtual box and Kimo it what will
provide is it will provide a installed
file it will give a folder where the
virtual box of VMware has already
installed K Linux so you can just load
up in your VMware system as you can see
you can it'll you have to choose open a
virtual machine if you download the
image directly this one so you can just
open up that folder and your operating
system will load on its own but while
after getting the ISO so you can
customize a lot of things the thing
about this virtual images are they're
not customizable as such with the iso I
can customize how much hard dis space I
want to devote to just the sandbox
operating system how much how much RAM
usage although those RAM usage and all
can be uh customized everything will be
tailor made based on your specific needs
so we will check that once the download
is completed which is just 1 minute
remaining apart from that you can see
there is a 64bit I think there is 32bit
as well I I'm not sure if 32 bit is
required nowadays considering everything
is
64 but yes before uh while the iso is
getting downloaded let's check out
VMware Workstation now to get started at
creating a Sandbox environment we will
touch upon create a new virtual
machine
yes uh here we can let's say check on
custom because we want to customize how
much we want to uh
give Hardware we can use workstation 16x
which is the latest
one now here I am going to choose I will
install the operating system later if I
give the ISO file here directly it will
install the operating system on its own
which kind of defeats the purpose if
that was the case we would have
downloaded the live image anyway we I
will click on I will install the
operating system later we will choose in
the guest operating system we will
choose Linux and make sure you choose
dbn 10x 64bit as we read in the
website it is based on dbn it's l dbn
based Linux distribution now this can
obviously change there are other
operating systems on which others can be
based like Fedora and uh Arch but this
one is dbn so we are going to choose dbn
over here dbn 10x 64bit which is the
latest
version click on next we will name it
as
Ki
Linux and click on next the number of
processors I'm going to give two
processors
here total processor course is four this
you can um determine based on how much
how powerful your syst is and how much
you can give as it is because a major
part of how how how a virtual machine
runs is not just how much RAM you give
to it is how much RAM is available
outside of a Sandbox environment because
if let's say your system is U has 8 GB
of RAM you devort 4 GB to the virtual
machine Windows itself takes up around 4
GB uh at least 3.5 GB when it's sitting
idle so you have to account for all that
when dedicating processors and more
importantly Ram as well so we going to
click on next for now and here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give 2.5 GBS
of ram which should be enough for the at
least the things that we are doing today
this can be customized later on as well
let's say you started working and then
you realize the amount of ram that you
have given it's just not enough and you
need a bit more then you can customize
that later for now I'm going to give 2.5
GBS of
ram you can see the recommended is 2 GB
anyway I'll just go a step further click
on next use Network address translation
is the network connection as in what
kind of networking it should have the
virtual sandbox should have considering
it is being run inside an operating
system your windows whatever internet
connection is given to your windows will
um go to k Linux directly but you can
customize that let's say you don't want
networking you want host only networking
that you connect the guest operating
system to VPN later on it's a completely
customizable process but for easiest
access we are going to use use Network
address
translation uh IO controller types LSI
is always going to be the most
recommended so just go ahead with it
choose a CI for the virtual dis type now
these are different virtual disk types
that can be used and they have different
purposes like some make it easier to
transition between multiple uh
installations of VMware or virtual box
based on what you have chosen but SCSI
is always considered the best disk would
be we will create a new virtual disk
now this is the maximum dis size or the
dis capacity how much hard dis storage
are we are going to devot for the
operating system installation and all
the files whatever you work in the
system that will be stored somewhere
right so we're going to devote the
basically the uh Rome size to make it
easier to understand so I will
give 30
gbits of memory size now here you have
another
option
uh you can actually allocate all dis
space now as it is written allocating
the full capacity can enhance
performance but requires all of the
physical display to be available right
now so the good thing about VMware is if
I think that's in Virtual box as well if
I do not click this even though I have
written 30 GBS it does not take up all
of the 30 GBS in your hard disk it takes
how much ever is required let's say
after installation and everything uh it
takes up 10 GB of space that is all that
will be taken enough it won't take up
all the 30 GBS the more you keep working
and slowly the data increases the size
increases of the virtual machine folder
it will go up to 30 GBS that's it so if
you allocate all of it now it will take
up the 30 GBS directly and it will be
slightly more performance because it
will remove that uh read functionality
when the virtual when the virtual
machine is being run so I will click it
and between these two options between
single files and multiple files single
files is faster but multiple files will
make it easier if you want to move your
virtual machine system from let's say
one laptop to another or you have to
switch between personal and official
systems but for now I can choose a
single file 13 disc file will be created
you can just put whatever name and I
think everything else is settled now
what we will do is we will click on
finish it will take some time to create
the
disk I think the iso download would have
been completed yes the iso download is
completed by
now it'll just take a while to create
the
disk uh there is also K net Hunter which
is a mobile penetration testing platform
it is available only on
Android uh you can use it to perform
small task obviously you can't you can't
perform everything that you can on K
Linux desktop environment but a lot of
the things can be performed like basic
Network scanning and some amount of
sniff and uh brute forcing tools all
those things can be performed on net
Hunter directly but that is a video for
another day so we'll just wait till the
dis is created and then we'll move
forward with the
process
as you can see the virtual machine is
now created so the next step would be to
actually align the ISO file so we're
going to click on edit virtual machine
settings
here we'll select the
cddvd position use ISO image file you're
going to browse
go to
downloads use the K Linux ISO and click
on
okay so now we can power
on select live system AMD 64 at all
times okay you can see a popup here
below that's says install dbn as
physical computer that we are going to
do which should be kalux in this case it
just shows Debian because it is based on
deban that's it when you're done and the
operating system boots Up Click I finish
installing so we will do that when the
time is
correct so you can see the live boot
running
up
for
okay you can see callux is booting up
now you get the uh the usage CPU usage
meter here and this should be the memory
yes okay so we have enter booted into
the desktop these are the multiple
workspaces but once again this is not
installed what we going have to do is
install this operating
system you can see you can use in the
live environment you can use everything
but you just have to install this
operating system
directly the networking system is
working
okay so once you familiarize yourself
with the K Linux operating system and
more importantly in the live environment
you are able to check if the amount of
ram that you have given and your
processor in general is able to sustain
everything or not we will what we will
do is we will just power off the virtual
machine again power on and this time
we'll not choose the live system what we
will choose is we'll go
down we'll choose the advanced
installation options we'll click
graphical install and install that's it
now what this will do is will launch the
graphical installer instead of the live
system uh some operating systems like uh
parro security for example will allow
you to install directly from the live
environment but that's it it's uh it's
not really a very big difference if you
run it from here or there now the
install installer is launched I'm sorry
uh we'll click the English language yes
uh it will ask for your location so that
it will set your time zone I will choose
India configure the keyboard you can
choose American English considering that
is the standard uh keyboard layouts that
is available on the market it will load
the additional components like the the
networking modules the input output
device detection drivers all those
things some of the partitioning devices
as well I think uh it will detect the
network Hardware
next
configuring configuring the network
withp yes uh now that we have to create
uh select the host name the host name I
will just keep it as Kali that's not a
very big deal this is more important if
you're a lot into networking and you
want to have you know particular home
network as a kind of like acting as a
server for the ENT all the devices in
your home Wi-Fi otherwise it's not an
issue uh and same thing with the domain
name I will skip the domain name because
it's not really essential for what we
are doing here yes but the username will
obviously be required the full name I
will give it as simple learn for
example
I'll keep the same username that was the
full name this is the
username uh password you can give based
on your wish make sure passwords the
same this is the single user by the way
you can obviously create multiple users
like we do on multiple uh other
operating systems now it will check the
disk partitioning here since we are
installing on VMware any virtualization
software be virtual box or VMware we
will use guided which is use entire disk
continue as you can see we had devoted
30gb it is showing 32.2 similar
situation here going to click on
continue all files in one partition
which is recommended for new users you
have you can partition it to home where
TMP may be a uh other partitions as well
that you can keep a swap partition as
well but that's not necessary now we'll
keep all of them in a single partition
make just make sure all the changes are
there it will create the swap memory on
its own and click on
continue it will ask that these the
changes being made just select yes
continue and it will start installing K
Linux into the V VMware virtual disk
this will take some time so we will
speed this up and come back to it when
the installation is
done so now we have to set the package
manager the main partitioning system is
done and most of the installation part
is done you just have to configure the
package Edge manager and use a network
mirror click on yes APD you don't need
to set up anything else here you can
just click on next and it will set up AP
which is the package manager of K Linux
now what the package manager will do is
help us install
uninstall update the tools and libraries
that K Linux uses all the softwares and
all the tools that we're going to use
later on it will configure the package
manager for
now
it's almost
done now it's installing the grab boot
loader which will uh uh when you start
up the system it will ask you where do
you want to log
in uh yes install the group grao order
to my primary drive click on continue
we'll just select Dev SDA which is is
you'll find a single U Drive anyway
instead of entering ENT device name
manually just click on whatever the
storage space is being uh written below
that if you're using it on Virtual box
or VMware which we are doing right now
you will get only one storage that's it
if you're dual booting you'll get
multiple and you'll have to make some
choices but that is Advanced and we
don't need to get into that right now
for now only the last one should be
enough now it is finalizing the
installation
just running a few post installation
clicks that's
all and as you can see the installation
is complete so please choose continue to
reboot uh we'll just press
continue
now it it uh loaded in a lot of the
packages during the live version and
during the installer so that it can
continue with the installation so it's
going to remove that live package now
from the
RAM and complete the
process
as you can see K Linux has rebooted and
is going to the installed operating
system
now you will learn if you're beginner
into Linux you will run into a lot of
the commands being shown just don't
freak out it's all
normal it does take some time to start
up depending on how much memory you have
given it um how much RAM you have
devoted to it how much even how much
hard disk you have given it also depends
on that and uh obviously it also relies
on how much memory your Windows
operating system is is using so that how
much extra Ram is available and how well
windows can push VMware Workstation so
you have the login screen we are going
to use whatever username and password we
had set during installation to
login now this will be the root user
you'll understand more about that just
now let's just allow it to boot
completely
okay so now we have K Linux operating
system installed and ready to go now
what I would recommend first thing is
just go around just check if you're new
to Linux uh do not make a lot of changes
or anything like that but do move around
for example if you can just click the
start button here which is termed as
applications you can see a lot of the
programs that are installed now the good
thing about kis it's very help uh
intuitive so for example information
gathering you'll see all the tools that
you can use for information gathering
now same for vulnerability analysis web
app analysis password attacks all the
brute forcing tools that you can use the
wireless attacks like aircrack uh reever
example sniffing networks like Yark Etc
so just go around the operating system
see uh check the file manager how it
works and you know basically get a feel
for the operating system directly okay
like see here's a file
manager just check everything how it's
working you can enter the settings and
move and make some small small changes
now a lot of the settings won't matter a
lot in when running virtually but it's
good to know and understand what are the
things that Linux offers so it's a very
important step one more thing if you are
in a virtual machine is make sure that
VMware tools is installed usually this
gets installed directly but if not you
can just reinstall here
okay I think so our environment is ready
and set up now as you might know a major
part of Linux is the command line so
we're going to click the terminal here
or we can just open right huh terminal
has
open so this is basically the command
line that you can use in Mac OS or
windows so a lot of the things that we
do on wind uh Linux is in the command
line itself now you can use General
graphical tools like uh let's say the
file manager for example you can do use
graphical tools you can use other
networking tools as well but it's some
it's always better to use the terminal
because one you can reach things faster
compared to a graphical tools
considering you just have to write a
single command and that's it for most of
the tools other than having to navigate
through a lot of menus and sections and
um other compartments that you have to
do on a graphical
interface so we would have to focus more
on this command line terminal and the
first thing that we have to learn in a
command line terminal is the sudo user
or the root user we had discussed uh
when creating the user where I told that
that will be the root user considering
we're only adding just one user for now
okay so let's break that apart actually
uh P Sudo is the keyword that we are
looking for okay now the super user or
the root user administrator of the
system is going to be someone who has
the all of the access to access
everything all the sensitive files all
the sensitive settings all those things
now if you can just see uh let's say if
I want to open a file I'm going to uh
put
cat
Etc
Shadow it's a permission denied cat is
the way to open up text files by the way
now this file does exist but I cannot
open it because the permission is denied
I'm not the root user right now I'm just
simply learn atate KH now the terminal
does not go into root mode by default
because it does it's not it's not safe
from a security perspective so we have
to check on what are the things that can
be done securely that's why what we will
do is we will write down now
sudo let's say it uh Sudo is the command
for and invoking the root user we will
write the same command which
is sud sudo cat shadow
it will ask you for your root password
that we set before we'll just put the
same password and as you can see it
showed the details of the Shadow
password uh Shadow file so why uh so
that's the reason actually why it's not
recommended to have the root user at all
times it's all uh it's not recommended
meanwhile what you can do is let's say
you work a lot with the sudo password
for example a lot of the things that
we're going to do in this video which
require the suro keybord which is the
root access now if you just open a new
tab for
example you'll get another terminal
without any issues now one thing I want
to note out is if you are learning a lot
of the tools Ed that require the sudo
command like opening sensitive files
like this one ATC Shadow or uh making
small small changes that require root
access like changing the network adapter
checking what kind of uh what kind of
external devices are being connected
from a syst system perspective all those
things you will require to run
continuously so instead of writing
pseudo again and again and again for
every command what you can use this
command Pudo Su now what this will do is
it will change the terminal uh change
the user in this particular terminal tab
to a root user now I will just press
enter and you can see you can check this
dollar sign here once I press on P sudo
Su this will change to a hash and you
can see the user has changed now from
the simply learn to the root user which
basically has all the permissions to do
whatever it can with the system it can
change into hash so now whatever you
have to do you don't have to write sudo
command anymore and just write edit shad
and there you go now remember this uh
root user terminal is only valid for
this particular tab not even this window
this particular tab if I go to this tab
here or I'll just close it and create a
new tab it's still dollar and we in the
simply learn user anyway you can't log
in directly to the root user for
security purposes like let's say if
while it is ultra rare for Linux to have
any kind of malware it is always better
to not give it all the permissions like
you can have in some other operating
system like Windows so you have to dial
into root directly okay so you can use
pseudo command uh you don't have to use
pseudo command if you have the pseudo
Su a lot of the things uh sometimes
you'll find commands that will not work
like the CC Shadow they will not work or
sometime the commands will work but they
won't work all the way you'll find
something is wrong so always make it a
point to try it with pseudo once before
moving
forward so now let's understand how we
can navigate the file system in Linux so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open the terminal again just increase
the size of the
text so as you can see uh this still
symbol this means we're at the home
location to understand how we can
determine which directory we are in
currently always remember terminal will
open in a particular Dory directly
that's the entire point of the terminal
or the command line for example to find
out what you are in right now you can
just type in the command PWD which
stands for present working directory
click enter and you can see I'm at the
home folder in the simply learn now this
can obviously change for example if I
want to move somewhere else now I'll
just open the file manager and show you
once this is the home simply learn
folder as you can see it is written here
tonar is the name of the file manager
this this is the home folder now you
have desktop documents downloads music
all these folders subfolders you can say
inside the simple learn folder home
folder so what I'm going to do is I'm
want to move to let's say the documents
folder okay so the command for that
would be CD which is change directory so
I'm going to write as you can see it'll
automatically try to complete the more
you use colinux and actually most of the
Linux operating systems the shell or The
Terminal understands where you go and
what you do all those things so so that
way I we're going to change the
directory to the uh let's say the
documents folder now we're going to just
write CD documents and as you can see
there is an
extra uh word here the documents which
means that now you are in the documents
we can use PWD command again to check
and you can see home simply learn
documents now what if you're at a
position where you don't know where uh
you are and what are the files that are
present there for example I just opened
this in the graphical user interface and
found out that okay these are the
subfolders that I can get into to
understand what are the folders
available at your particular location
the command is just listing for command
is LS press enter okay this is the
documents apologies we'll just to go
back one step right now we are in home
simply learned documents to go back a
single step we just write CD double dot
double full stop then you can see once
again we are back to home simply learn
now once again to understand what are
the folders that are present we have to
use the command l LS and as you can see
you can see everything that is present
the desktop document downloads music
pictures all those folders can pop up
now you can move here and there based on
where you want to go apart from this
let's say if you want to create a new
folder for your own one thing we can do
is
mkdir that command stands for make
directory now if I want to create a new
folder by the name of
mkdir SLP now remember make sure you
understand which position we are at
which is right now home simply learn
based on the last PWD I haven't used CD
command anything after that so now if I
press LS you can see another folder in
the name of SLP now you can do the same
things you can just go to SLP you can
see the uh path has now changed to home
simply learn SLP you can go back and
that's how you can work and create
folders to delete let's say I don't want
to have the SLP folder anymore I'll just
use rmd
SLP now if I check LS we don't have that
folder anymore so that's how you work in
between folders now one more thing that
you can do is just clear and it will
clear up the terminal for you now just
to check where we are again home simply
learn now remember seeing the uh cat
folder right uh the cat F uh sorry the
cat command using the ETC folder and the
shadow file now let's say if I want to
see what is inside the ETC file for
example if I just put down LS it will
only show me what the the folders
present in my present work
directory what I can do is I can just
write
LS
Etc and these are the folders that are
present in the ETC folder so you can
check other files listings here as
well and directly giving the full path
so that will ignore the current working
direct the present working directory and
show the folders present in the path
that you
mention okay apart from that one more
thing that we need to know when it comes
to listing out details is the LA command
now all of these commands this LS PWD at
least 90% of the commands that you're
going to use in the Linux terminal I
just clear this for now 90% of the
commands that you use in Linux will have
sub commands or uh it also called as
flags that go along with it now for
example in my current present working
directory if I press on LS I get these
folders right but these are not the only
folders that are present these are the
only folders that are being shown now to
see the other files and folders that are
present in the form folder I can write
the normal command Ls I'm going to add a
sub command or a flag if you say hyphen
LA and you can see there are much more
than the desktop documents downloads
that something that we were already
seeing here but apart from that you can
see other files and folders here that
docash doc config bash logout everything
you can see now everything that has a
DOT or full stop uh before it is
considered a hidden file it's not going
to show up directly using LS you have to
write the LA command which will show all
the files now it's very important to
understand these sub commands and what
are the flags that can be used in
different purposes this is basically the
shell so the more research you do and
understand what kind of flags that you
can use it's going to be easier what can
help here is the man command the man
basically stands for manual you can find
it in every Linux actually let's say you
want to learn what are the flags that
you can use with the ls command for
example or you just want to know what
that command is
so you can just type in man
LS and you see it basically says LS
stands for list directory contents is is
a description here you can see all the
sub commands the flag minus B minus D
there's a good explanation for every
single sub command that you can use in
order to navigate to the file system or
just listing this is just for LS command
you can do this with almost any command
that you want it says once you are uh
once you've read what you needed to know
just press Q to quit and there you have
it so that's all about how to list
commands uh uh list folders and navigate
through file systems using CD mkdd and
RFD now about the commands that you saw
and all the folders that you were able
to see let's say if I just press lsla a
you can see there is a folder called
cach right so to enter the file you also
need to just use the C comma you can see
the present looking director has changed
you can just pres press LS here and see
if anything else yes you can see there
are other folders here as well so the
entire process Remains the Same but just
understand that if there are some files
and folders that you're not able to see
which is going to happen a lot
considering a lot of the things that are
hidden in Linux by default you can
access all of those things but you need
to know the right commands and the right
way to access them so if you are missing
out on some files and folders just make
sure you can uh you're using the ls
command and sometimes even the LA
command to get the details of of
everything that you missing now this
folder currently doesn't have as such
any a lot of missing files and folders
like the home folder had so right now
it's not very indicative but you get the
full idea of it another thing that you
can use apart from the let's say the man
command is the help command help uh
hyphen hyphen help this is a small this
is not as detailed as man and this
doesn't work for all commands but you
can do a lot of the commands uh if you
need a quick answer to something you can
definitely check this out which is a
hyphen hyphen
help so while we clear about folders
like how to manipulate folders let's
take a look about how we're going to
work with files for example now let's
say uh you use the echo command Echo
command is the equivalent of trying to
put something on screen so let's say if
I just press Echo with the codes it just
print out hello if I want to put it
inside a file I'll just
say uh just press control Z I'll just
pray Echo hello to autocomplete just
press the right arrow on your keyboard
it will auto complete uh after that Echo
hello I want to put this into a file
let's
say uh my
file.txt
yes uh we'll do one thing this is
currently in the cache folder right
we'll just go
back yes this is the home folder so
we're going to do the same thing here
now to go back to our history of
commands I want to do the same thing I
want to Echo hello into a new file so
I'll just press the up arrow and it will
go cycle through my recent commands so
I'll just press enter and if I just
press s LS now you can see in the home
folder there's a new file of my file do
text okay if I want to let's say move
this file to one of these folders let's
say I want to move this to the video
folders so the command for that is c p
which is copy I will copy the my
file do text to the videos
folder so I'll just enter I don't need
to actually enter videos to see the
files like we had discussed so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to just type in
LS
videos and you can see it has the my
file. text folder since I copied it
obviously the home home folder will also
have the my file text in order to remove
the my file text I have to use the RM
command remember to remove directories
we used RM
to remove files we just have to use RM
so I'm going to use RM my file. text to
delete the file now if I LS the home
folder does not have but since it had in
the I had copied uh kept a copy in the
videos folder I'll press LS
videos press enter and you can see it
still has the my file
command okay now one more thing that we
going need to know is the move command
the move command will essentially move
whatever folder wherever you want let's
say I want to create Echo hello my file
again I press LS and I'll see the my
file.txt folder now if I want to move
this file let's
say if I use the MV command instead of
the CP command which is just for a I
want to use the my file.txt to let's say
the downloads
folder it's saying permission deny so
what I will do is I will click on Pudo
like we discussed a lot of the things
will not work directly we will use the
same
command we use the downloads
folder it will now work it's time to
take a look at users and privileges now
if you remember a LS command uh let's
just check my present working directory
it's the home folder now if you remember
the L minus L A you see a lot of the um
characters here is Dr W XR all those
things now this is basically to
understand what fold or what permissions
a user has if you check here there are
folders and files you can see the
folders in the dark blue color and the
files in the white color you can see
Light Blue for links but that's a
completely separate uh thing so another
thing the permissions part if you see
there are three groups here this is a
first group this is the second group
this is the third group the first group
is the owner of the file now what
permissions does the owner have now for
example right now the owner of let's say
this one uh this file for example is
root most of the time it will be the
user but this time it is root it has uh
read write execute R for read W for
write and X for execute obviously the
owner will be able to do all those
things now the second group is basically
for anyone who is part of the uh domain
group in the users like if if you
remember while installing there was a a
option called create a domain while we
did not create it because we don't have
a lot of users right now but when you
create a domain what are the people in
the group who are going to do so they
have the read function which is RX for
execute but they do not have the right
function they cannot write directly in
this fight similarly for the third Group
which is anyone outside of the group so
any other user if they are not in a
particular group of the file then they
also have a read function and the
execute function but they will not be
able to write into the file directly so
that's how you can check all of the
files that are able to uh that a user
can access or not access that's
basically the entire purpose of the uh
the privilege section because we don't
want to give undue permission to a
people who do not require it the entire
point of security in Linux is to be is
level of abstraction that is providing
users with exactly what they needed so
if you have a user that does not
required executable functions to let's
say the downloads folder we can cut it
off from R and as a root user anyway so
so that's about providing Privileges and
providing access to certain
files now like we had discussed the ETC
Shadow file that we had uh used when
checking the cat file now one more thing
that we can do again is understanding
what the shadow file does if it just
press cat Etc Shadow obviously it will
not work it will just say permission
denied we're going to say suro cat
Shadow this basically has the password
hashes for all the users that are in a
system right now you can see the root
had does not have a hash because it's
not safe to have a particular hash for a
bruer just from security perspective uh
we the the user that we have created
which is simply learn you can see the
password hash being mentioned here now
depends on how many users you get if you
create three four five users you can see
all the pass password hashes here now
you can uh if the why this is password
protected by security and we need to use
the pseudo user command is because if
someone has this hash let's say if
someone is a cryptographer and is able
to Brute Force through hashes then it's
very it's going to be very easy to try
and figure out the passwords to
particular users passwords that's why
even the hash is not shown with uh full
confidence unless and until they get the
pseudo user command so that's about uh
you know uh privileges and how you can
use the sudo command to bypass the
normal user limits so now let's take a
look at some of the networking commands
we're going to clear this one for
now uh to check the adapters that we
have in use right now you can just write
if config or actually IPA uh sorry not
see IPA uh similar information IPA is a
newer variant it basically shows what
are the adapters and the networking um
conditions right now for example you can
see ethernet now even though I am using
Wi-Fi on my local system
uh in network address translation which
is the natat that we set the network
package manager when setting up the
virtual machine virtual machine on this
VMware it will link up as ethernet so
you can see ethernet you can check our
local address you can check the 24
subnet this is our broadcast address and
this is our Mac address for the system
this is our IPv6 address as well now
similarly uh this can be checked on
whichever system you are being connected
to the IPA at uh if config is the same
it's just uh an older variant apart from
this there is another command actually
IW config now this is particularly for
wireless oh sorry uh that was a wrong
spelling I have IW config now right now
it will not show any Wireless extensions
if you are looking into Wireless
sniffing uh Network package detection or
even Wireless hacking for example we
will publish a video video on wireless
hacking soon so stay tuned for that
apart from apart from Wireless hacking
if you are using any Wireless extensions
let's say we have small adapters that
people can use as portable or wireless
cards for Wi-Fi from some systems that
do not have Wi-Fi enabled n's in their
motherboards the people use modifiable
custom uh portable um adapters so if you
have one of those plugged in you will
see it in IW config from if config you
will only may be able to find out the IP
address and that's it config will give
you all the information and you can
check later coming to different IP
addresses a command that you should be
knowing
is
ARP now if you're not familiar with ARP
that is going to be a address resolution
protocol I think ipn will also show the
same information so what both of these
do is it basically states which IP
address relates to what Mac address it
will also show which one isable which
one is stable all those extra stuff now
remember whatever is being done in these
kind of uh IP addresses and Mac
addresses all of them need to be put in
a routing table if you want to connect
with each other now how you can check
that just enter route and you can see
the routing table for this particular
system you can see there is a
destination for every IP address there's
an open Gateway there is a mask here all
of this stuff whatever data need they
needs to travel in between host now the
second host let's say from this virtual
machine I want to travel I I want the to
communicate with a system that is in my
similar wi in the same Wi-Fi network
then there must be a routing table
connection between them this can uh the
example that I gave that the same Wi-Fi
network thing that will mostly be
handled by the a modem or the the router
basically but what if it's not what if
there's there's just two systems and
they're not having any other connection
and you just had to happen to have a uh
a land cable connected between them you
have to set these routing tables
manually so that you're able to
communicate this is going to be
expressly useful if you're setting up in
a domain group authorities and all those
things but apart from that it's just a
good thing to know how networking works
now all of these commands these Mac
addresses these IP addresses these are
something that are of outmost importance
so learning networking when learning
Linux is very essential I highly suggest
learn networking so that you can be able
to grasp these things better now based
on how you can communicate with
particular host addresses there is a
command if you want to check if you can
reach a particular host or not that is
using the Ping command now we'll take a
common example for this because I don't
have any other system in the uh uh
vicinity Network right now so let's say
if I want to uh let's I want to see if I
have connection to google.com now you
can use directly an IP address as well
I'm just going to check ping
google.com and you can see it'll start
pinging request directly from the
google.com server whichever is the
nearest server that Google has
set you can see it just says that it did
it's s 64 bytes from this particular IP
address it received an icmp request was
sent the time it took for each request
is also mentioned at the end here 15 Ms
16 Ms 17 18 all those Ms now since we
are getting a particular request back I
basically requ uh needs a response if we
are getting a response then that host is
reachable if I did not have internet
right now this would not be possible
I'll just show I'll press control C
whatever uh whatever command is being
run if you want to stop it on the next
terminal it is best to uh it is control
C okay just press contr C I will it will
give a small report here as well it says
51 package transmitted 50 received how
how much packet loss was there if some
of the request did not go through or did
not receive a response how much time it
was taken all those things I'm going to
clear and what I'm going to do I'm going
to
disconnect yes the network connection
has been disconnected now if I put ping.
gooogle um sorry ping.
google.com temporary failure in name
resolution as simple as that so once I
connect
again head started pretty
straightforward apart from using um
domain names you can also use IP
addresses like we mentioned now another
IP address that we can ping for sure
since we have internet connection is
cloud Flair DNS resolution address now
that would be ping
1.11.1 now better to have to understand
DNS it's basically acts as an address
book for all the websites that you see
in whichever way it may be for example
if let's say we're reaching google.com
when we pin google.com we saw this IP
address responding a request whenin saw
google.com particularly responding to
requests right these IP address will
depend based on what uh what D services
Google has and what kind how many
servers they have in particular
locations that's why uh hitting IP
address directly also work that's why
DNS is essential so we're going to Ping
1.11.1 and you can see we're getting
response times for those as well now
these will be generally faster compared
to normal you know
websites as you can see the time is much
less compared to pinging google.com
okay uh obviously if you can't Target
something let's say 1. 1. 2.5 for
example I'm not sure if that is even a
host 100% prum loss it's just
um nothing
worked it will not work it won't send
anything even if there is a host let's
say if uh I have an IP address address
of a system that is in my group but it
does not have permission to receive IPM
request or it has just closed off all
the ports that we cannot connect with it
then it'll just not work it will just
say it's not existing think you see we
sent 26 packets none of them were
received and it was a 100% packet loss
that's why I'll just check once what is
the IP address of our system plus 1921
72130 5 1 192 168 72 130 I'll just 154
or
something something there is no host if
there was another address there it would
have received some request and since
there is no host it says destination
host
unreachable that's how you can check if
you have connectivity with a particular
with a particular system in your network
or your group or your domain using the
Ping command so that's the networking
commands that all the networking
commands that you need to know for now
the basics at the very least the next
thing you have to take a look at is
Services now services will differ widely
based on the system that you using for
example on Windows you see services for
different stuff like for any remote Exel
software you check and you see Services
similar cases with Linux if I just open
let's say
htop okay do we have to install H stop
let's just use stop here it basically
functions the top functions as a task m
man you can see so many systems Services
here xog tonar xtop this running on the
background stuff like that now if I want
to start something particular let's take
the Apache web server now Apache web
servers have been in use for like like
years decades at this point so in order
to function uh see how Apache servers
used the first thing I'm going to check
is my IP address this is my IP address
so what I'll do is I will copy this I'll
open my web browser aparture web servers
are hosted on your own IP so I'll just
paste it here and click enter and you
can see there's nothing popping up now
now a major reason can this uh for for
this can be the server is not running so
one thing what we do is we're going to
start the apach server by starting its
service so we're going to use
system start uh so sorry system aparture
to start now if I click
enter it'll say it just not work what I
will do is uh sorry this correct term
was service not system and even if I
click on service Apache to
start it'll say it needs authentication
now this could be bypassed by directly
giving Pudo and putting in the root
password in the command line itself but
all in all it's the same result so I'll
just use my password Here
and now I just remove the HTTP here
because Apache is a local server now you
can see the Apache web server has loaded
based on approach different default P
now as you can see the server is working
correctly if I just open the terminal
again now to stop it I can once again
just go s Service Apache to stop this
will stop the service I'll just press
enter I'll refresh and there we lose our
access a very good part of a purchase
servers used to be the ability to hold
files ability to host files basically
for people in the same domain or even
the same network okay now you can see
where the files can be stored like for
example it says you should place this
file located at where HTML index. a so
if I just open up my file explorer and
go to file system where www HTML this is
where a lot of people can poost their
files okay now another better way is to
hold up python server now considering
all of Linux come almost every single
Linux distribution now comes with python
pre-installed so how we can do that
is uh let that keep running we don't
have an
issue just check no actually let's stop
that it'll be easier to understand how
it's working if you refresh now as you
you can see nothing is working so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start a python HTTP
server python H python minus m is the
sub flag for it and HTTP server we're
going to start now what is my present
working directory simply let me just
clear these present working directory is
the home folder if you check what are
the folders that are available desktop
uh documents ders these are the folders
now if I am running the HTTP server on
this folder even even though it'll only
my IP is going to be used for accessing
the server it depends on which folder
I'm hosting it from so if I host the
python HTTP
server wait uh python HTTP server from
this folder I just press enter and you
can see it says serving HTTP on 00 is
basically your local IP address and I'm
using the port 80 you can use whichever
Port that's not really important which
Port you use by refresh now you can see
I see all the folders that aable doop
documents downloads these do are
something other things that we've
already seen using the minus l a comma
so all the files are now hosted properly
as expected
similarly if we want to use let's say
any other files that we want to share
with someone in a network uh easily and
this can very well function like an FTP
server this is not exactly FTP server
but this can be easily accessed with
just the URL if someone is in my system
if someone is in my home network for
example they can just just use my IP
address which will be 19 to1 168 72130
they can check the Ping command and see
if it is reachable which it should be
unless until some particular Port is
closed they can just access the files
using this one now to stop the python
HTTP server once again just press contrl
C and it's gone so that's how you work
with services in K indux at least from a
a a basic perspective that's how it's
going to
work now one of the last things that
we're going to check is the ability to
install update tools and basically all
the software that you can see here you
see all the
applications that can be run for example
the one liberity analysis tools n map
SQL map um rever uh pixiewps all those
things now how do these get installed
updated and basically dealt with so PT
actually APD get also but uh uh those
are interchangeable and you can use
whichever one you like I use
APK but in order to check let's say if
you want to update a system which is one
of the bare minimum needs of every
system right so the command for that is
going to be so uh first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to use Pudo Su which
is the PSE sudo super user I will just
use pseudo Su and going to the root
stage because almost all of the commands
that I'm going to put next require sudo
so I might as well just be without
having to type the password every single
time now once time sud use you the
currect command would be AP get update
now what this will do is it will check
the repositories every L distribution
has a few repositories that it gets the
softwares and updates from it will check
the package list now for now the
repository that is being hit is a call.
download Khali rolling in release right
so it will update the repositories based
on the data available on that particular
address we use the AP get update command
there so next thing what we are going to
do is AP get
upgrade yes so now after the
repositories have been updated with the
data available on the web server it says
that the following packages will be
upgraded you can see the Apache to
server needs an update then you have CS
certificate script setup Firefox CSI
which is a Firefox browser for extended
support release Linux platforms all
those things the Misa wcon drivers
python python flask all those things out
of a total 33 upgraded no new
installations are needed
and four need not be upgraded so after
this operation you'll see 364 MB of
files needs to be downloaded and 24 M
additional displays will be used you can
either continue using y or n so that's
how you're going to update your system
if I just even if I click n and be done
with it this is all about updating I'm
going to clear this out but how do we
install files for example if you
remember I typed out a command called
htop it says command htop not found but
can be installed with ap install htop
that can once again be AP get as well
it's not a very big deal which one do
you use I'll just cancel this and I will
write out the command myself I will use
let's use APD for this one instead of
APD cat APD install edrop now I am able
to do this very easily because edrop is
already in the repository I have uh that
in the Kali in Rolling release
repository that's why as you can see the
installation has been started this is
the the fetched 152 KB which is the size
of HR it's a very small thing and the
installation is now complete now if I
just sit on EDG stop you can see a new
version of the the the task manager or
the system monitor essentially to uh see
what kind of WEA the memory is being
usage the CPU percentage all those
things so that's how you can install if
I press contrl C again I'll go back to
my command line interface so that's how
you can
install I uh to remove you can just use
apt remove HTTP it says want to remove
and 387 kiloby dis will be be free if I
just press enter we don't have WTOP
anymore so that's how you install and
remove tools from K Linux using the AP
and APD cat now these AP and apdk are
package managers specifically for dbn
and dbn based operating systems that's
why these commands will transition uh
will be consistent across all dbn Bas
Distribution Systems unless and until
they have their own package manager
which is not really the case if they're
based on DBL so similarly feda has dnf
Arch has Pacman all those things so
those will differ but if in a particular
um in a particular base distribution
these package managers will be the same
so that's how you can use AP and EP get
to understand how you can install and
remove tools if you want to embar on a
successful career as a cyber security
professional than have postgraduate
program in cyber security the course
link is in the description box below
ethical hacking interview questions
ethical hacking is an integral part of
cyber security and it is gaining lot
prominence today with the increase in
the number of cyber attacks in this
video we will run you through the top 20
ethical hacking interview questions
based on Concepts like networking
software and programming operating
system and applications cyber attacks
and cryptography so let's get started
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn let's start off with
question one what is a
firewall now this is a very good
question and normally
a very basic answer that I've ever heard
is that a firewall is a hardware and a
software firewall but that's the
functionality of a firewall that is what
how you can install a firewall but there
are different types of firewalls and
there is a specific functionality that a
firewall is created for right so
firewall is either a hardware or
software but its responsibility is for
blocking either incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer they secure a network so
essentially the firewall will allow a
connection to happen or disallow a
connection to happen it won't go beyond
that that's the basic functionality of a
firewall okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on
the firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that Network or some traffic
is to be blocked from entering that
Network so as the screen shows the
firewall rules will analyze whether the
traffic is good if yes it will allow if
the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will anal analyze
the contents of that packet which is not
correct when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of De packet
inspection or DPI as it is known if that
capability comes into the picture you're
basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
NextGen firewall okay so a packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data packets for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that connection to happen or
disallow that connection from
happening the second type of is a proxy
firewall these firewalls filter Network
traffic at the application Level So when
you say application Level they work at
the layer seven of the OSI model packet
filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they work on IP
addressing and port numbers will work on
the network layer of the OSI model also
on the transport layer because they also
look at protocols proxy firewalls will
work at layer 7even which is the uh
application layer of the OSI model and
will deal with application Level
protocol such as HTTP https FTP SMTP and
so on so forth and the third one is a
stateful multi-layer inspection firewall
uh these filter packets are the network
transport and application layers so they
basically do the job of the first and
the second type of
firewalls the packets are compared to
known uh trusted packets but now the
first question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and pro proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall is to allow good traffic
and this allow bad traffic based on the
rules that have been configured on the
firewall and then you've got basically
three types of firewalls packet
filtering proxy and stateful multilayer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls so that's
question one moving on to the question
two what is a VPN VPN is also called a
virtual private Network it is a
connection between a VPN server and a
VPN client so it basically creates a
encrypted tunnel between the client and
the VPN server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram the user has a VPN
client installed on the machine the VPN
client then creates a an encrypted
tunnel to the VPN
server and through this tunnel encrypted
data is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can received
can be received back by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to EES
drop on the communication mechanism they
will not be able to do so because of the
encrypted T it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel it is possible but it
is very difficult to achieve that then
question number three how do you keep a
computer secure now this is going to be
a very generic question so you want to
put your best foot forward and you want
to identify the most common
methodologies on how you can keep a
computer secure so when we talk about
computers the first thing that you want
to talk about is authentication
mechanisms where you want multiactor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure that your accounts are keept
secured now if you look at using
passwords depending on how passwords are
being stored by the application uh
password attacks can be possible either
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
base attack uh or even password guessing
attacks are possible to mitigate those
kind of attacks you we need multiactor
authentication to ensure that accounts
are secure now even if we are using
multiactor authentication we also want
to look at secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as uh meet has at
least one lowercase one uppercase
character has numerics and special
characters and his randomize is not
based on a dictionary word doesn't
doesn't contain usernames email
addresses phone numbers or anything that
is personal to that particular user
third keep regular updates which means
that there will be patches that will be
released for the application for the
software that you're utilizing download
the patches install them on a regular
basis to ensure that you are secured
against the most recent attacks that
have been
identified install a good antivirus
could be a Internet Security Suite which
will have an antivirus intrusion
detection system a firewall uh and will
help you protect yourself against
ransomwares
malwares and any script based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host based firewall or
a network based firewall to ensure that
uh attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices have anti-
fishing softwares installed as well to
ensure sure that you are not getting any
spam mails even if you do you're able to
identify that and not fall prey or
victim to those spam males fishing
attacks are generic where they are
directed towards
individuals uh and they pray on the
gullibility of that particular
individual so our Nigerian frauds or the
lotteries that we win on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars uh those
messages the emails that we received
they are all fishing emails where uh
they're basically prone to victimize the
user and then Rob them of money or uh
install some
malware or do some other malicious
activity if you want to enhance
encryption about data that you have
stored on your devices or on your or
that is accessed by your software or
being transmitted by your software use
encryption encrypt your data whether it
is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use thus reducing data
leakage and data loss uh possibility
ities and finally and the foremost
secure your DNS DNS is the domain name
server which is utilized
by computers to resolve domain names to
IP
addresses if a DNS poisoning attack is
possible where your DNS settings have
been modified by an attacker and you
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you you don't want
people to know your DNS servers and the
queries that you're making so you want
to use secure DNS or uh DNS over https
to encrypt your DNS queries as
well so in a nutshell if you follow
these eight steps your devices your
computers your applications are going to
be as secure as possible moving on to
the question number four what are the
different sources of malware now malware
stands for malicious software right
malware is basically basically a
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload of errosion
virus pyware key logger or some malici
software that is going to have a
negative impact on security of your
particular device so the question here
is what are the different sources of
malware we want to identify the most
common sources through which malware
infect end user devices in today's world
and it can start with popup ads so most
of the websites if you're visiting
untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about there will be a lot of pop-ups
coming your way where it says you're the
1 millionth visitor to this site please
click here to download your gift or it
will say uh congratulations on winning a
particular product for visiting this
page and so on so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you on top of the
page and says that there are eight uh
infections that have been identified on
your computer click here to download and
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these
popups are there as a social engineering
attack as a fishing attack to make
gullible people click on those links and
download those malwares now the software
that is posing as a security software
itself can be a malicious software which
is going to install a Trojan or a virus
or a bot on your machine compromising
the security of that machine the second
is removable media USBS and humans have
a fascination with USBS so if you find a
USB lying around it's a free USB you get
excited about it and you want to take it
home you want to plug in into a machine
and see what's on the USB worst case
scenario you format it and you got a
free USB to utilize higher the capacity
the better but that is one of the most
easiest way people use malw to uh to be
deployed on unsuspecting users if there
is a USB lying around why would why
would somebody want to forget a US USB
it's most likely planted over there as a
social engineering attack so that a
gullible person is going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough it is going to
install the malware right uh then
documents and executable files this is
where your viruses and uh all those
Creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software uh and you find the software on
a particular website you do not verify
the trust worthiness of that site and
you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source to ensure that it is
trustworthy and only then are you going
to download and execute those files does
internet downloads as well and when we
say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrent uh
we go to uh the dark web or the Deep Web
and we searching for other softwares
especially uh those who are researching
security right we always want we always
on the lookout of new softwares and we
always on those forums which may not be
so much trustworthy and we just download
those files and start installing them
that is a very bad scenario right so you
have to be very careful what you're
downloading from the internet your
antiviruses your uh anti- fishing uh
mechanisms your threat intelligence
mechanisms uh have those uh mechanisms
installed and you want to verify where
your downloads are coming from then your
network connections if it is a P2P
connection it is a local area network
connection or a metropolitan area
network you have to verify whom which
devices are connected to your machines
and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices uh and before you connect
to them if you are on a public Wi-Fi you
probably don't want to connect to a
public Wi-Fi in the first
place then comes email
attachments there are so many
attachments that come across in today's
world most of them in a zip format or a
RAR format uh some of them come as
document files where there are macros
hidden within them macros are scripts
that are recognized by Microsoft Office
files right and then finally there are
these malicious advertisements that we
find online right uh Let It Be Facebook
let it be WhatsApp let it be uh any
social media platform that you go or
even your uh search engines their job is
to display ads their job is not to
verify whether the ad is legit or not it
is for us as consumers to be careful and
validate that ad and verify whether it
is a genuine ad or not so just don't
start clicking on uh any of the ad
trusting uh the platform that you're on
be uh be sure that you are investigating
that ad so these are the most common
sources of malware and the end
user will always you get infected by one
of these mechanisms then moving on to
question number five how does email work
now this is a very uh can be a complex
question uh but we have to keep it as
simple as possible and we have to
identify that there are uh two servers
where both of them either using SMTP
where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where uh in this
scenario John wants to send an email
thus they've got a email client
installed on their machine which is
connected to the mail Exchange Server
which has a DNS server which Maps the
routing and uh which maps The Exchange
Server and inboxes so when John composes
that message and clicks on send John
should be connected to a m Exchange
Server where the email is sent through
that particular person's inbox so John's
inbox will then uh be validated and that
email will then be sent through the DNS
server uh through the internet and will
be received by the recipient mail server
so at this point in time John also
requires the recipient's email address
so in this case this is Jack so Jack
something.com would be uh the email
address so when John is composing uh the
two field will have Jack's email address
the from field will have John's email
address the subject field will have uh
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when uh John
clicks on send it will go to their
Exchange Server The Exchange Server will
then validate the Inbox and identify
where that inbox is located for Jack and
then through the internet it will be
sent to Thea uh to the mail server of
Jack the mail server will then identify
the proper inbox that it that that email
needs to be sent to and it will store
that email in that particular inbox when
Jack opens their computer and accesses
their inbox this email from from John
will be already waiting for them and
they can respond to it the same way John
had sent that email moving on to
question number six what is blackbox and
white box testing so when you are
testing a software or you're testing
your infrastructure there are two
different test that you can conduct the
first one is a black box the second one
is a white box in a black box test there
is no knowledge that is shared with the
tester so let's say you're a ethical
hacker and you have been awarded a
contract by an organization to test
their current application that they have
developed now they're not going to give
you any information they're not going to
tell you what the application is they
just probably give you an IP address and
a port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to fire in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
can lead to in security incident so
without any knowledge zero knowledge of
the it infrastructure or the source code
that's a blackbox attack or a blackbox
test a white box test on the other hand
is where full knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a blackbox audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody
who's corrupt who has been bribed who
wants to sell out company Secrets based
so they're going to try to find out Vol
abilities try to steal data and try to
sell it on the uh gray market right so a
white box would emulate internal attack
a blackbox would emulate an external
attack the next question is what are the
steps involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of ethical
hacking question you're looking at
devices and for uh and the interviewer
asks you uh what kind of steps are
involved what are the activities that
you would do in hacking a server or an
Network now there are no specific steps
that you would Define because every hack
is going to be unique but it has a hack
can be classified in five different
steps which are quite generic right so
the first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase the attacker gathers
all the evidence all the information
that is possible about the targets that
they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victim so you
can launch specific attacks towards them
you want to identify what operating
system they utilizing what IP addresses
Mac addresses the versions of the
operating systems and applications the
patch levels find out vulnerabilities
find out whatever information is
possible find out the information about
the uh person who's using those
computers so he can launch social
engineering attacks and so on so forth
so the first step is all about gathering
enough information based on which you
can launch further attacks once you have
that information comes the second phase
which is known as the scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so you
have uh in the first step you have got
your IP addresses domain names maybe
even Network maps and you have
identified which devices are available
now in the scanning phase you're going
to identify live
devices and then you're going to scan
them for open ports processes protocols
Serv Services you're going to identify
vulnerabilities you're going to
enumerate them to identify more
information from them thus at this point
in time you will have identified a
certain set of vulnerabilities or a
certain set of security loopholes that
you can
misuse once you have identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access tape in this you're
actually going to execute your attacks
based on the viabilities that you have
found and you're either going to gain
access to that particular system by
installing a rosion or destroy the
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaining
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you have gained in the
first and the second phase you're going
to launch your attacks and you're going
to try to gain access to that particular
device then the next step is where
you're going to maintain that access now
that you have hacked into that device it
is not necessary that you will always be
able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have crack the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access so this is where it
is assumed that you want repeated access
to that device and thus you're going to
install a key logger or a Trojan or some
mechanism which will still allow you to
get access to that device without the
knowledge or the authorization of that
particular user and finally the last
step is where you're going to cover Your
Tracks so whatever activ that you have
done so far will have created logs and
will have created information based on
which the victim will come to know that
they have been compromised and may be
able to trace that activity back to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked and to prevent them to discover
who has hacked them you want to cover
your tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you're going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed it ran or a key logger these
will create files and directories you're
going to hide them so that they are not
discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have been
compromised so these are the five steps
that will be involved in hacking a
server Network application or any
Computing device you'll come across the
next question refers to what are the
various sniffing tools now this is a
network based attack where you're trying
to capture data packets that that are
being transmitted over the network and
then you're going to analyze them to see
if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
Bank details or anything of that sort
now these tools would also depend on
which operating system you're utilizing
for example MSN sniffer would work on
Microsoft uh operating systems eer cab
would be based on Linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems wi shark is
uh something that is common both on
Windows and
Linux uh it is used to analyze Network
in details it is the defacto tool that
you will come across in most of your
ethical hacking trainings in most of
your organizations when they want to do
uh data
captures now data capturing or packet
capturing is not only done by hackers to
gather more information but is also a
known troubleshooting Tech technique
used by administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so the first tool you see on the
screen is wi shark like we stated is
available for Windows Linux uh as well
then there is TCP dump which uh again
has the same capability of wire shockk
but is a command line version whereas wi
shockk also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dump is available on Linux
Ms and sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had MSN Messengers uh MSN
Messenger is no longer there but
Microsoft does or did have a Microsoft
message analyzer Tool uh which they have
stopped development since 2015 uh but
that's another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft that can be installed to
gather more information then you got eer
cap which is a tool to launch man inth
middle attacks data capturing and is is
essentially a a Linux command line based
tool then D sniff is another password
and network capturing tool which can
help you capture data package
prominently a Linux uh tool same with
e this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to uh capture data data
traffics and map protocols and identify
which IP addresses have been
communicating with what essentially all
of the tools have similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like launching man in the
middle attacks or capturing or having
specific filters that will help you
identify and troubleshoot some network
issues that you may be facing question n
what is SQL injection SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language that is used by most of your
databases or your relational databases
uh the the variations of your database
would be MySQL Microsoft SQL Oracle
SQL you'll have IBM databases all of
these databases utilize the structured
query languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for but as
the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability or a structured query
language injection vulnerability is
where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input of or a SQL statement in a
query and send it to the database and
evoke a respon response out of it so
this varability is not specifically to
the database it uh the varability lies
more in the application and the coding
of that application so when the
application receives a query which it
needs to be forwarded to the SQL uh
database we need to configure at the
application Level of what queries are
allowed and what queries are not allowed
so there are different various
aspects of how to manage a SQL injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a response that was not
warranted there are various types of SQL
injections uh as shown on the screen
inband SQL injection where you can look
at an error based or a union based
injection
a blind SQL injection where it is either
Boolean based or a Time based attack and
then an out of bound SQL injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security where you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated then the
next question is what is spoofing now in
spoofing you're basically assuming the
identity of another person so here the
attacker pretends to be some other
person or an organization and sends you
an em email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been and
it is very difficult to spot a fake one
there are different ways to identify
whether an email is genuine or not if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more moving on to the next question what
is is a distributed denial of service
attack or a Dos attack now generally a
denial of service attack is an attack
where legitimate users are prevented
access to the resources that they
legitimately can access right so for
example if it is a bandwidth based
attack the attacker consumes the
bandwidth of the network in such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users to access the network
now a single device may not be a bble to
generate that much amount of uh traffic
to consume the bandwidth of a youth
server thus the attacker will construct
a botnet and through that botnet they
will launch a distributed denal of
service attack to the Target victim
right so a botnet uh there are two uh
terms that we want to look at over here
the first term is a bot and the second
one being the botn net itself bot is a
software that once installed on a
victim's machine allows the the hacker
to uh send remote commands to that
machine that will make it do generate
some
activity once we have enough machines uh
on which such Bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet so an attacker
would then instruct this entire botnet
to start generating data traffic to be
to be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crash ing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular resource the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once your
computer boots up it starts a discovery
process of identifying its neighbors so
if I'm in a particular subnet my machine
will proactively send out ARP requests
an address resolution protocol to find
out which other machines are within the
same network and which are live once it
sends out a query a live machine will
respond to that query along with its Mac
address this information is then stored
in what is known as a ARP table or an AR
table on the machine's cache so whenever
my machine now wants to send out a
packet to this particular machine it
will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh IP and destination Mac
and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
MAC address send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch now to confuse
the switch into sending it to a
different machine our poisoning attack
is created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the- Middle
attack now to prevent this AR poisoning
from happening in the first place there
are three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering which will fil filter out and
block packets that have the same Source
address data so you have identified some
malicious IP addresses and you want to
block out some IP addresses so you're
using a packet filter firewall where you
have instructed the firewall to filter
out certain
packets originating from particular
range of IP addresses this firewall and
this technique will then block those
kind of packets coming in second keeping
away from trust relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from that once you
have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be sending out ARP request to other
machines in the first place since uh the
trust relation has has been defined and
these machines know whom to communicate
with such kind of protocols should then
be disabled or you can use ARP spoofing
software so there are some there are
softwares out there that will look for
ARP spoofing and prevent that from
happening in the first place so if
somebody has sent out a spoofed ARP
packet that packet will be picked up by
this software and it will be mitigated
of network visualizers like glass wire
antiviruses like soof force uh they have
inbuilt capabilities of identifying
op spoofing attacks and mitigate them in
the first place in the next question
we're going to discuss what is
ransomware now ransomware is a type of
malware that blocks victims to access
personal files and demands Ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories let's
just revisit what ransomware is let's
start with the word malware malware is a
malicious software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine
so in this instance viruses Trojans all
of these can be classified under males
so can Ransom wge a troan is a software
that will give you a backd door access
to a to a particular device a virus will
do some destructive activity on that
device a ransomware will basically
encrypt the data of that particular user
from on that particular machine thus
rendering that that data inaccessible to
the users themselves and in turn will
demand a ransom to provide access to
that particular data so the three types
of ransomwares the first one is
scareware which uses social social
engineering to cause anxiety or the
perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this prays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a popup appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a bir software to mitigate that
particular virus now the malware will be
in this software that you will be
downloading and then a ransomware will
be installed and your data will be
encrypted screen lockers uh where
locking users computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log to
your own machine but it will give you a
warning that data has been encrypted and
you need to connect to a particular
email address and send bit send Bitcoins
over there uh to get a decryption key to
access your own data and then the
encrypting ransomware displays a message
demanding payment in return for the
private asymmetric key which is needed
to decrypt the symmetric keys for
encrypted file so once your files have
been encrypted you might just have a
blank screen in front of you where
you'll receive a warning message uh
where it instructs you to pay up a
ransom in bit Bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency to some particular
digital ewallet which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data then talking about
the next question what is the difference
between an active and a passive Cyber
attack now when we talk about cyber
attacks Cyber attack is a activity that
is caused by a malicious user who wants
to try to get access or do some security
incidents on the victim's devices
so there are two ways that can happen
it's either in an active manner or a
passive manner in an active manner the
Intruder attempts to disrupt a network
normaly modifies data and tries to alter
the systems resources so this is more
active where the attacker will
proactively uh try to destroy the
network so that Communications fail or
they might try to modify the data where
uh we're using a ransom where they can
encrypt it or they might delete that
data using a virus or steal that data
using a Trojan or they might even alter
the data uh so that it is no longer
trustworthy whereas in a passive attack
the Intruder intercepts data traveling
through a network here the intrud EES
drop but does not modify the message so
they're just listening in they're just
observing what is going on they are not
manipulating the data they're not
stealing anything it's just that they
are monitoring the activity that's going
on the the next question what is a
social engineering attack now social
engineering attack is a people-based
attack the victim here is the Human by
itself the viability also lies in the
human it may be executed through a
computer but end of the day the gabil is
of the human so it is the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving up confidential information now
we always reading the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they shared
the OTP with someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
pre to this attack and share this kind
of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in creating
that scenario which will ensure that
these people give out this confidential
information now there are three
categories in this attack well the first
one is a fishing attack second is a
spear fishing attack and a third is a
veiling attack now fishing attack is
basically a generic attack it is
targeted To The World At Large whoever
Falls bre to that attack will be a
victim whereas a spear fishing attack is
a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into spear
fishing where you analyze the victim you
try to figure out what their
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people will then fall prey
to this attack attack and availing
attack is where you're
attacking top level Executives so the
sea level Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people uh so any of these
people when they're attacked it will be
known as a veiling attack next question
what is man in the-middle attack now
this is something that we had touched
based when we talked about ARP where the
ARP poisoning attack needs to be
executed to leverage a man in the middle
attack now
in the man in the- Middle attack the
attacker attacking computer takes the IP
address of the client unaware of this
the server continues to communicate with
the attacker now if you remember in a
previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario uh
attacker has spoofed their IP address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either through a r poisoning
attack or just because of the spoofed I
IP address become a man in the middle
that means that they are now EES
dropping on the conversation between the
actual client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now a go between between
the client and the server and can e drop
and can copy the data if they want they
can modify the data as well so as as you
can see on the screen the attacker
becomes man in the middle which means
that they are now even is dropping on
the conversation that is happening
between the client and the server the
next question who are blackhead hackers
and white hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a blackhead
hacker and a white hacker now a
blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals who illegally hack into a
system the motive behind such an attack
is mostly for monetary gain these
individuals are known also known as
security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers those who have
malicious intent those who do hacking
for the intent of personal gain or for
the a matter of disruption the main
thing that blackhead hackers lack is
authorization they are not authorized to
do the activity that they are about to
do and they're going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data which is
going to cause losses to the
organization involved whereas on the
other side a whiteed hacker are are also
known as ethical hackers these are the
individuals who discover vulnerabilities
in a computer
network and they help the organizations
mitigate these vulnerabilities they help
the organizations defend themselves from
blackhead hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack from by finding out
vulnerabilities they also will not have
authorization to conduct whatever
activity they are doing whereas on the
other side whad hackers will be hired by
organizations they will provide
authorization for certain activity that
the white head hacker can do to find out
those vulnerabilities once those
vulnerabilities have been find out found
out by the white hat hacker they will
report it to the management and guide
them in implementing security controls
to mitigate those bilities the main
difference between a black hat and a
white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are honey
pots now honey Poots are a very
interesting device that can be
introduced in an network uh these
basically are decoy servers that are
implemented in a network to attract the
attention of a attacker it is there to
lure an attacker uh into uh attacking
that particular device thus creating a
security blanket blanket for the rest of
the devices so if an attacker has been
able to bypass a firewall and is now
trying to scan a particular Network when
they Scan they will come across various
devices that are there in the network
they will then proceed to do a avability
scan on these devices the honey part at
that point in time will provide as an
approve as an attraction to these
attackers because it will demonstrate
some vulnerabilities to the hacker which
will divert their attention so these
vulnerabilities are simulated on these
devices these actually do not exist but
the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honey poot the
honey pot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honey pod of what activi is
going on and then reconfigure their
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server uh that
will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them and Safeguard the rest of the
network moving on to the next question
Define cryptography encryption and
decryption now cryptography is used by
Security Professionals to scramble data
into non-readable format uh which is
used in securing that
information so it involves converting
data from a readable format into a
non-readable format and then reversing
it back to readable format again for
example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult for a human to figure out
what the actual word was now in this
scenario we have taken an algorithm
where we have made a shift of the
alphabet where we have added two
alphabets the current one so C + 2
becomes e o + 2 becomes q m + 2 becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus two so
any person who figures that out we'll be
able to unscramble this and convert this
back into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about now as we discussed the
decryption again is uh replacing the
alphabet and taking it further back by
two characters so e - 2 becomes c q - 2
becomes o o - 2 becomes M and so so on
so forth so anybody who knows this key
uh the shift
key anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet +
5 then the spacing the shifting of that
character will be the fifth character
from that particular character and so on
so forth and now the last question what
is the difference between Cipher text
and clear text Cipher text refers to the
text which is encrypted and totally
undesirable
the message received after the
decryption is known as clear text this
text is comprehensible so the word
computer is clear text that means that
it has not been treated to any
cryptographic measures it is what it is
intended to be however if the moment we
encrypt it that means we scramble it
into unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at that
text is known as a cipher text and
without the key this becomes
unreadable the clear text as discussed
is the plain word that we have utilized
we are using the English language in
this instance so the plain word computer
is the clear text once we add the
encryption layer to it uh we get the
cipher text to it with that we have
reached to end of this full course if
you have any questions please feel free
to leave us a comment and we will have
it answered for you at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here